called to order the
uh Health and Human Services and elderly
Affairs committee meeting for today and
we are starting with a meet and greet
because these are folks that will come
often before us to testify on various
matters so these are people from the um
Department of Health and Human Services
they will introduce themselves say a few
words about what they
do and we'll go from there Maestro
Williams
Mike good morning everyone my name is
Lori shonet I am the Commissioner of
Health and Human Services um I'm I'm
about two years into my four-year term
so you should see me for about another
two years um people call me the covid
commissioner but I do more than covid uh
so um I've been with the department for
about five years um as the CEO of New
Hampshire hospital Deputy Commissioner
before that and prior to that I was CEO
at marac County nursing home for about
16 years I'm a nurse by training um I'm
my probably my specialty areas are
behavioral health and long-term care so
I usually do a commissioner's update at
each HHS oversight meeting in my absence
if I'm trip triple booked then my Deputy
Commissioner Lori Weaver will usually
stand in in my place and do an update uh
good morning Lori Weaver uh Deputy
Commissioner for the Department uh been
with the Department 25 years next month
uh did not grow up in the department
though had a life before the department
but my life for the last 25 years has
been the department um I currently
oversee all of operations within the
department as you probably aware the
Department's rather large I also support
all of the policy areas in the
department as well so pretty much any
ball that's moving in the court to make
sure it's moving on the court doesn't
break doesn't get hurt and makes it to
the end um so before that I was an
associate commissioner for about three
years and various leadership roles in
the department in different program
areas over the 25 years it's nice to
meet you all thank
[Music]
you
good morning chairman peersman committee
members thank you for allowing us to
meet with you today my name is Jonathan
Ballard I work as the chief medical
officer for the Department I've been
with the department for four years I a
family medicine physician and an
epidemiologist um prior to this role I
worked as the state epidemiologist for
the state of Kentucky I did train the in
New Hampshire been here off and on since
2009 um and I am still on occasion a
practicing Family Medicine physician I
work at the department mainly in
clinical roles answering questions
around medical
protocols um resource for the Medicaid
Program on eligibility determination
when there's a clinical question and
support other areas of the department on
uh essentially medical clinical
questions through the covid-19 p
pandemic I've been your resource for uh
channeling questions reaching out to
different areas of the department and
helping legislators and others find
answers that may need uh you need so I
still continue to do that job and if
there are questions that you have for
covid-19 then I think I will be your
first Outreach and I'm happy to to at
least try to find the answer oftentimes
I will not know the answer
good morning chair good morning
committee my name is Patricia Tilly I am
the director of the division of Public
Health Services I've had the privilege
of being a frequent flyer to this
committee for a number of years I've
been with the department for over 20
years starting out working in maternal
and child health population health I had
also been the deputy director I've been
the director for about six months now I
think I officially took that role in May
um public health is more than covid-19
although that is what is on all of our
minds almost all of the time Public
Health however promotes and protects the
health of all people and um protects
that Health within communities where we
live work learn and play and while a
doctor like uh treats people who are
sick it's our job in public health to
try and prevent people from getting sick
in the first place and the way we do
that is through the incredible work um
throughout our division that is pretty
Broad and and with the chair's
permission I'm just going to have some
of my team members just wave from the
gallery as I introduce them is that okay
you may wave thank
you thank you so much so um first we
have Ian Watt and I'm sure he's waving
in the background right now he is our
new deputy director here at the division
of Public Health Services he's come to
us from Los Angeles and has an
incredible background in emergency
preparedness which has served us well
throughout the um throughout the
pandemic we also have with us Abby
Rogers who many of you know is our
legislative liaison for the division of
Public Health I anticipate that aby's
going to be here even more than ever as
we have a number of bills as you know in
front of you and it's going to take an
entire team to address them I also have
with me Sai Chala Dr Sai Chala again
well known to this committee she uh
takes care of us Cradle to grave she is
our population health expert and knows
all things child health tobacco I think
there were have some conversations about
tobacco a little bit more um and chronic
disease and nutrition we have Michelle
Rober she is our chief of Public Health
protection again an important part of
our division um working on things like
lead poisoning prevention you'll see her
pretty soon as well um food protection
uh radiological health and other areas
that are regulatory in nature with
Michelle is Colleen Smith who is the
expert on all things food so so she go
to her if you have a question around our
food safety and um regulatory practices
with our food service providers um I
have with me chawe Chala um and chawe is
one of the smartest ladies you'll ever
meet she is our data expert she knows
all about privacy and data governance
and works closely with Dave weeders who
you'll see in a minute and then finally
with me I have Amry McCurry and she is
our new immunization section section
chief that's hard for me to say
um and we have a number of bills in
front of you this year about vaccine and
so an Marie and I will be taking the
lead in addressing those bills so thank
you very much and um we're always here
to help you thanks the Department of
work good morning representative and
members of the committee thank you for
having us here my name is David weeders
I'm the information Services director
for Health and Human Services and really
what my role is to provide technology
and information um support for all of
the divisions that you're going to meet
today um our our role is to really help
improve those solutions to provide
streamline um Services um make it more
effective for our individuals that we
serve in our
state uh I'm I'm going to be
particularly interested in privacy
security interoperability and
integration legislation that you're
going to be hearing throughout this this
session so you'll be hearing from me as
a support arm of our different division
directors as it impacts those different
areas I'll go ahead and introduce Ernie
Gillan or go ahead good morning everyone
it's nice to meet you all I am Ernie
Gillan I am the deputy director for
Information Services and my role with
the Department is really to support
everyone else in this room as well to
make sure that they uh have everything
they need to have from a system
solutions to be able to help the
citizens of our state um I focus more
operationally and then execute the
strategies and directions that the
leadership
directs and as a legislative liaison I'm
paying close attention to anything data
and security related that's going
through appreciate the opportunity to
meet you all
you good morning we did not coordinate
our outfits just thought I'd note that
in advance my name is Karen Hebert and I
am the director of the division of
Economic and housing stability we
oversee several bureaus in this division
including the Bureau of child Support
Services the Bureau of housing
supports the Bureau of Employment
supports the Bureau of family
assistance and the Bureau of Child
Development and Head Start collaboration
and the uh eligibility integrated
eligibility system known as New
Heights you may hear from me uh
regarding items that come before you
related to food insecurity
or housing or
homelessness and child
care so I've provided you uh at the end
of the session today with some
information handout information about
the services that we
provide uh as well as a list of other
individuals from our programs that you
may hear from from time to
time so please reach out my contact
information is on that information uh so
please reach out out to me if you have
questions and I'd like to introduce our
deputy
director good morning my name is Marty
IL and I'm the deputy director of the
division of Economic and housing
stability I'm a New Hampshire native I
came from the nonprofit sector and I've
been in this role for two years so I
entered um right at the beginning of
covid and um that's been my experience
so far I can help you specifically with
topics like early childhood in including
Child Care and Family Support Services
which are delivered in our communities
Centers hello good morning uh thank you
for having me my name is Melissa St sier
I'm the chief legal officer for the
Department of Health and Human Services
so I'm part of the senior executive team
with the commissioner and Deputy
Commissioner um so you'll see me here
for a variety of reasons um but the
office of legal and Regulatory Services
is the is the um is the office that I'm
in I'm I oversee so that includes the
Bureau of Licensing and certification
for health facilities and childcare
licensing that includes the two um
budman's offices the the regular um
budman's office as well as the long-term
care um budman's office the
administrative Appeals Unit um
legislative services and I think that
might be it I'm trying to remember um so
I'm just going to introduce I do I
forgot to tell you about myself um other
than uh law law is actually my second
career I was a nursing home
administrator so I was um I I was in the
healthcare field and I worked in that
for 15 years before I went back to law
school so health law and and um
obviously the health of of our state is
really important to me and so this uh
this job is kind of the perfect fit for
for all of my experience background so
hello everyone um so we have through the
Bureau of Licensing and
certification uh the administrator the
manager of that Bureau is dorine shley
she's in the audience there she is thank
you um Kelly Tom you'll also see Kelly
is an attorney uh you've probably seen
her already um and she is she uh
represents the Bureau of Licensing and
certification and will be here um for
that and maybe other um interests as
well um through the office of legal and
Regulatory services and then as you all
know John Williams uh who does our all
of our legislative work um and so I
don't know John if you want to come up
and and say something really quickly
you're welcome too but thank you it was
counselor
keep uh this sheet please because uh
we'll need it for next week plus it's
got all the information the acronyms are
on the back page also I asked uh
councelor Williams if he could put
together a cheat sheet
that lets us all know who are the
principles in each of the subsections of
the department we get phone calls from
constituents or in my case I got a lot
of phone calls from other
legislators asking who do I talk to on
such and such uh this sheet will be
invaluable it will also cut down on the
phone calls I place to John Williams
because now I've got the cheat sheet so
hold on to
this also we have some packets that have
been put together by different people
and uh we're going to hand hand what I
keep those oh they are packets you're
going to be each given a set of handouts
from the different people we've just
heard from which further explain what
they do and how to get a hold of them
that
and you've you've kept out two packets
rightt one we actually need three
today thank you thank you a couple
things you also received a packet of all
the bills we will be looking at this
next several months you will not be
getting another packet that's especially
an exhortation to myself who can lose
things while standing
still so that these are the
Bills and there will not be
individual groups of the bills we're
going to hear on a particular day at
least that's what they've told us so far
so keep hold of the
packets please use the
microphone I don't hear well to begin
with and I hear even worse when I leave
my hearing aids at home which is what I
did
today we need to know that we cannot
withdraw a bill once we've got the bill
in our possession it cannot be
withdrawn these bills were prepared last
summer and we went through the process
in September and so on and so on and in
some cases
things have changed and the sponsor
Prime sponsor other sponsors of the
bill have frequently said oh if I knew
now what I if I knew then what I know
now I would not have filed this bill or
I certainly wouldn't have filed it in
this manner I've already received a few
phone calls from people saying I wish to
have my bill
ited we still have to have a hearing but
that's really where the Miranda warning
should kick in you have the right to
remain silent please use it in other
words there's no need to have testimony
you may do so if you wish but I ask what
the point is of having a whole series of
people testify on a bill the sponsor of
which wishes it to be itl so we'll we'll
speak about that when these matters come
right before
us
the house rules are if you are prime
sponsor or co-sponsor of a
bill before
us you can't you can
questions however during the exact
session it's everybody for him and
herself you can speak you can question
you can exhort you can do all kinds of
things during the hearing however you
questions we would ask and please let
everyone know who's coming your friends
coming to testify on various things we
would like the written testimony turned
in at the beginning of the hearing if
you're here to testify on a bill turn
that into the clerk and as my friend and
predecessor reminded
me the clerk doesn't have to take
extensive notes on testimony if the
testimony is basically all also
available in written
form so if we have testimony on
something get it up here
early we're all trying to figure out and
remember how we do this in person so
we'll be patient with each other any
questions on
open the hearing on House Bill
1616 relative to the prohibition against
a Minor's possession of hypodermic
needles without a
prescription and pink cards on that
please send them up this way and if
there's any written testimony please
send that up this way and the chair
calls on representative yoka to present
16 thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Joshua
yella
I representing Rockingham
33 Fremont Danville and
Brentwood I have written testimony
getting passed around this way the CDC
um uh recommendation uh passed around
this way and hopefully um everyone will
expecting
so so I wanted to start with a few
examples of what I believe um is the
issue if if a a teenager is watching
their their um younger sibling with the
permission of their their parents and
it's given an epip pin
or um insulin for the younger sibling
that they're
watching in fact both of the the parent
and the kid for accepting it has
committed a crime in New
Hampshire if a friend has recently di if
a child is recently diagnosed
with um a condition that would lead to
anaphylaxis and they get uh their brand
new e pin and they they um show their
friend that they hang out with all the
time
they um they hand it to them they show
how how they they would need to use it
if they were
incapacitated the handing it to the
friend they've both committed a crime in
New
Hampshire if a teenager let's say is
cleaning up the
streets and finds a needle on the ground
that is used picks it up takes it to the
pharmacy or police station for proper
disposal that child has committed a
crime and then let's the last example is
um if a kid has has a prescription
for
uh uh a needle and like is at school and
they need to to give themselves insulin
and they drop the needle on the ground
and it's dirty and they need to dispose
of that and they go to the nurse to ask
for an addition like an extra one um and
the nurse has one and they called the
parents and got permission the this the
nurse is not allowed to give that to the
child they would need uh an additional
prescription for that
needle um to give to the child and
so my so I came across this in this this
uh bill or I came across this statute
which is um since my bill is repealing
the statute in the back um the second
page of my testimony um that first group
of language where it says control and
possession of hypmic needle are like
instruments without a prescription of
minors that is what is suggested to be
repealed
um and I came across this when I was
looking
for um
information on on occupational licenses
because this bill this this law is in
the requirement uh is in the statute for
pharmacies and Pharmacists and so the
penalties for anyone breaking this law
is the same penalty as a pharmacy
pharmacist which is a
misdemeanor for um it it doesn't give a
class so it would be Class B which is up
to a $1,200 fine unless the da requests
that it would be um changed to a class A
which would be a year in prison up to a
year in prison and a $2,000 fund and and
um I think that this committee and we as
a nation have have started to move away
from
um treating addiction as a criminal
activity and more of a mental health um
activity that needs to be treated by the
parents and the and the physician and
not the judicial system and so that is
why I am proposing that we repeal the um
the requirement that we put um the kids
into the legal system because of
this um and I am proposing that we study
and keep it would still be a crime if
this legislation passes for an adult to
give a minor
a a syringe or epip pin or whatever that
they don't not have a prescription
for however I think that you guys should
study that issue and whether or not it's
the proper penalty the proper um section
of law um and if there should be
exceptions for something like um all the
other Medical
um or drugs that are are prescribed have
a prescription there is an exception for
being able to have an authorized user
handle that in the um in the event that
they need help administering that
prescription to the person that it was
prescribed to for example if your
parents have cancer or something like
that and you wanted to help um prepare
the medication for your
parents
under this under current law that would
not be allowed if it was in a
syringe um and so there was an I I would
like you guys to consider maybe an
exception for that and
I um there is in in some of on the
second page I
included uh the the section of Law
31842 and underlined the authorized
agent um section of that uh so that you
guys would know exactly where where I'm
talking about that you could copy the
language and put it into this stat the
um other part of the statute if you um
deem that
necessary and so I think that in general
I think that we should just not be um
putting the kids into unnecessary legal
battles and um and and obviously um the
thing that I sent sent around from the
CDC is they believe they we've kind of
gone away as as a
health um in our view of Health away
from trying to restrict access access to
Needles because of the um trying to
reduce the transmission of bloodborne
pathogens and um so that this is some
information about that and what the CDC
recommends um is to get rid um allow for
the legal sell of needles without a
prescription is what the CD
recommends um but I'm happy to take any
questions thank you any questions for
representative
kerk
oh I am T thank you for the bill the
question I have though you say two
members of the house from hhsa given
that some of this has to do with
criminal penalties should it be be
member from Criminal Justice and one
from hhsa instead because we don't have
much uh knowledge about criminal penalty
issues
I I just put the the members that I
thought would be have an interest in
this so if you yes I I think that that's
a reasonable
um change to be made yeah absolutely
thank you for the question
thank you thank you um can you explain
on no no I'll try again better better
sorry no problem can you just explain to
me the um where you believe um this
establishment of the commission
intersects with it sounds like some
other like Judiciary might have some
input in this so I was curious ious to
know if you had heard input around some
of those issues when drafting
this um so speaking to the um study
commission I recommended um a police
officer a school nurse a pharmacist all
be included um I talked to the chair of
Criminal Justice and
they
um
they did not say they had a strong
feeling about wanting to be included so
I did
not include them
so any other
folsome mind plays music okay we're on
um thank you Mr chair thank you
representative yoka um we talked a
little bit this morning already about
this and I was wondering would you be
open to working with a couple members to
come up with an amendment to address the
issues now so that rather than repealing
and putting it into a study committee we
fix those
exemptions uh now with a bill so it goes
goes into effect right away this you
know this session and if then we still
see there's another problem maybe come
up with something next year but at least
we could
address some of the quick
issues thank you for the question uh if
you believe that this is a s simple uh
solution then I'm absolutely happy to
work with anyone I thought that it was a
complicated issue about whether or not
what kind of exceptions we would want to
make um but if there are clear
exceptions um for the adults um then
obviously i' would be happy to work with
anyone that wants to on that um I
thought it was a very complicated issue
about whether or not we would want to um
allow adults to give like unrestricted
access to to kids kind of thing so I I
kind of AED on the on the side of
caution on that representative yella the
chairs of all the Committees are under
immense pressure from the speaker's
office not to have
commissions as one who is increasingly
asked to go find people for the
speaker's office I can tell you it is an
increasingly difficult job because those
people who have the time to do it and
the ability and the inclination are less
than 400 believe me fewer than 400 um
and some of the people I've asked who
would have been great on this or that
commission have said they're already on
four and they don't want to be on
another one my suggestion and it's only
that is if you pulled an ad hoc group of
people representing numbers of the
categories you have in your bill and
pull them together as a study group and
did it on the fast quick you could bring
an amendment as the clerk has suggested
back to us in about four to six weeks
that
would obviate the need for a commission
and accomplish what a good commission
would probably do that's just a
suggestion I hate to see this shot down
commission I'm not sure that was a
question but thank you thank you Mr
chair all right would you believe I
believe that I I believe that you would
believe that and um I will take that
under advisor and anyone that is
interested please get in contact with me
representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question would you be
willing to consider as a way of dealing
with your issues
simply uh as a beginning
step having a list of exemptions with
protection for the
M minor which seems to me to be your
major concern is not saddling a kid
who's pick picking trash and has a
needle in their possession with a
misdemeanor conviction right and that's
a stretch but but perhaps a list of
exceptions for the minor without getting
into the larger morass of what adults
May provide to miners might be a first
step in dealing with the concerns you
had
without um getting too deep into the
weeds and uh the question was actually
would you be willing to consider that I
question thank you any other questions
for representative
m would you believe uh that um instead
of forming a commission that the
oversight committee on Health and Human
Services allows ex that committee to
have work groups uh and that could solve
the problem of forming a committee uh
possibility I was not aware of that but
thank you for that information thank you
wasn't
sir thank you for your testimony
representative yala thank
you the chair calls Abby Rogers from d
Services good morning chairman Pearson
and members of the committee for the
record my name is Abby Rogers and the
legislative lison for the division of
Public Health Services um when we read
the title of um representative's Bill we
thought it was more relative to um
syringe service program so that's the
information that I was prepared to
delivered today so since that is not the
topic of the bill I don't really have
any further comments unless um you'd
like to hear more about um syringe
service programs which I don't think
it's the intent of of the
representative's bill today thank you so
you and
the next pink card I have is from the
New Hampshire State Police from Captain
Joe AB bear a
bear all those years and Bill brigh
[Music]
thank you members of the committee and
chairman uh good morning my name is Joe
Ebert I'm a captain with the state
police I oversee the Investigative
Services Bureau which is our
detectives this is uh Lieutenant bill
brigh and I oversee the narcotics
investigations unit with State l so uh
on the on a on the whole we don't oppose
the bill uh one notion that we have it
seems to as written repeal the current
statute uh prior to a study committee uh
that is one piece of the bill that we
would oppose uh I'm sure there were
valid reasons uh for why the bill was
written why it became an RSA as it
stands now so we would want to uh have
further research into that uh before we
uh repeal that so it seems to be putting
the cart before the horse to repeal the
bill then do the study I understand the
chair's position on commissions or the
uh the greater bodies Commission uh
position on commissions um that's that's
uh certainly Far Over My Head uh but we
are more than willing to participate in
any commission study group ad hoc group
or anything else uh as it relates to uh
questions thank you officers appreciate
easy first day of testimony thank you
very
much
seeing nothing further no more pink
done for for you to get ready next up
will be
starting at
10:15 and it's not yet 10:15 so a long
slow walk
representative
caner who is um substituting you can
tell us why you are substituting to
present this and that this is an early
bill so we have to get it out the
door yes yeah we start we're not we're
not he's just T he is just telling us
why he's up here but we're not going to
start it until it's advertised time
minutes does anyone have written
testimony on this that can be passed
either to everyone if you have multiple
copies or to the clerk if not and any
pink
cards on this yet to be heard Bill 1642
FN may come forward at this time as
well and I don't think you want my
written testimony because I just hly
wrote it in the last 50 minutes oh
sorry you don't want my written
testimony because it's in my chicken
scratches and my worst grade in all of
elementary school was penmanship so my
fate was decided at that point and you
took a graduate degree in bad penmanship
called an MD degree exctly exactly and
the issue is that uh Chu grassy is the
sponsor of this bill I had not intended
to testify but CH grassy has covid and
so he's not going to be here today and
so I was notified about 20 minutes ago
that we needed somebody so I volunteered
well thank you you can sit tight for
about yes about two minutes and so uh
anybody have any good jokes
no
where well that's the whole point when
in fourth grade when my worst got my
lowest grade in all of Elementary School
in penmanship I knew that I had to go
ahead with my plan of being a doc it was
it was
ordained so I I don't think you want to
writing my wife can sometimes figure it
out I remember that time when I had to
read something for you that you weren't
allowed to read yes and it all went well
until I inadvertently looked at you and
said Jerry what's that word and that
totally gave it away although I think
the chair at the time was on to us uh
yes I think she I'm afraid the chair was
yeah we uh Mr chairman
no because of that issue I'm so pleased
that a lot of the prescriptions today
are done
them hey Mark do you want to borrow one
of my hearing aids
sure Jerry this is my first time to be
in a hearing since I got him and man it
is nice to be able to understand what
the people are saying yes you've joined
us yes yeah make sure you clean the wax
guards yeah every night every night so
if you want to share wax I can give you
one of mine but I don't think you want
okay but no not Blood Brothers wax
Brothers oh yeah thank you for yeah too
much information Fran is
indicating well we're in the final
countdown yes and we still have to have
fun okay well if we have to have fun my
father never got us a actual dishwasher
because he considered me the dishwasher
so maybe today I'll be our Chairman's
hearing aid perfect just like in my home
in massachus so I'm not quite sure that
the wording is correct I think perhaps
our DHHS people can clarify that for us
a little bit better so again I was not
prepared to testify um it just happen to
know a lot about this and I I did review
it particularly when uh the issue came
up with our Greg grandson uh I can try
to take questions if you have
some any questions any question any
questions for the representative
representative
Merchant thank you chair thank you
representative for taking my question um
I believe the underlying bill has a lot
of Merit and it does make a lot of sense
and clont we spent tremendous amount of
time and energy talking about lead
poisoning and so forth as a community
we've done tremendous amount of work in
this direction so it's really critically
important that this is addressed somehow
the questions to you is when you get
into testing not all testing is done at
the physician's office Clara we have
people who actually allowed to do the
testing um the test results could go to
the physician's office they go to the
parents and for the parents to take the
action the second question is we have a
lot of mobile parents that go between
communities and a lot of times between
states so my concern is that you could
have a situation where the parent or the
child has been tested with the parents
permission but that information may not
be readily available for those in the
school districts in New Hampshire so
having some sort of a database is going
to be critical because most of the time
the parent may not actually have the
card or retain the card so the question
to you I guess is how do we deal with
the issue of public testing versus that
being done to the medical provider and
then number two what do we do with out
of state residents that move into the
state uh certainly a good question but I
know there's usually not much appetite
for databases in this state uh so I I
doubt that's going to get a warm
reception um but by the same
token you know perhaps requiring that um
of course even if you require that it go
to the primary provider a lot of people
don't have a primary provider so this is
a real problem I don't know a good way
around that um if somebody comes up with
a good idea then we can certainly bring
that forth as an amendment but I had not
thought about that thank
you representative
gay since uh since we really want to
encourage people to do the testing and
data collecting is Handy at schools how
expensive would it be to do the testing
at school since it's just a finger
stick well I think one could argue uh at
school or at daycare because again we
want to catch these kids in that first
year or two and in fact even more
troubling is many daycares will not take
a child either under 18 months or under
three years so you know it's the old
closing the Barn Door after the horse is
already out so this this is a bit of a
problem but you're your point is correct
I do not know there' be certainly um um
consent issues as we have in a bill
coming up in a little bit later uh I do
not know how expensive these machines
are they would be a matter of utility if
a lot of kids come in already with tests
it may not be very cost-effective to be
trying to do that and we'd have to be
somehow allotting some money to the
schools to do that followup
followup has do we have any other
program where a mobile unit goes from
place from place to place I will defer
that to DHHS because they would probably
answer it better than
I and I think they are here to testify
yes yes they're here to
um hopefully yes thank you Mr shair and
thank you representative um I understand
just how critical it is to get these um
children tested early and identify them
um I'm curious if it would make more
sense to figure out how to get better
compliance with the one and two-year-old
testing at the doctors as opposed to
waiting until as you said possibly 18
months 3 years or 6 years old if they're
not even going to daycare yes I think
though the um the portions in sections
three and four are trying to get at that
as Healthcare Providers shall report on
a form developed accounting of all
children referred for blood double
testing the results and then of course
the last part uh they have to tell how
many children in their practice so that
means that DHHS can look at it and say
you have a compliance rate that's 10%
that's abysmal I mean you know so
there's not an enforcement thing but it
would be an issue of there's nothing
better than the light of day showing
that you're not doing well um you know
you could even argue have the insurers
do it because we know that we have a lot
of we tracked a lot of ways for a lot of
our metrics in terms of quality of care
this is a metric for quality of care but
since a lot of the kids may not be
insured that may not be a very good
thing so the idea is to for HHS or I
presume even licensing board to follow
up with shoty
care but I I I agree with you that's why
I think this again I didn't write this
bill but I think the idea was to have
multiple prongs of attack um multiple
layers get the information from
providers have a backup of when they go
to daycare have another backup when they
go to school I think that was the goal
of
it thank you sure representative
kofalt thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative so I just wanted to
uh clarify a couple of things I heard so
you said by the time you learn that
there is lead poisoning it's too late
um I my understanding though is what
you're really trying to do is to avoid
continued exposure is or is there is
early intervent is there an advantage to
early intervention or is it more a
question of preventing further prolonged
exposure or both um I am going to
probably defer that to I have to confess
I started writing this about 20 minutes
before I had to get in the hot seat and
I've forgotten if this is one where we
can do some keying to yeah okay good but
we can do some keying to try to remove
it
uh to get the blood level down I was
pretty sure we could but I wasn't
certain thank you very much professor
salaway and also yes to stop the
continued exposure and also people that
have one child may just possibly have
another one um so this is and also there
are a lot of issues about notification
that occur within s247 in terms of the
housing stock if we have uh a child who
is a high blood blood level so yes you
can do some things about it but you may
not be able to reverse all the damage
that's already occurred thank you thanks
representative
King okay can you hear me no
[Laughter]
yes hearing aids noar hearing aids um
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for uh taking this
question which I think uh already covers
some of it and that is um you know what
do we
do this bill I think it it's great if we
test the kids and the question is what
happens when we start finding more and
more kids that that test positive and
I'm even thinking of like um you know a
lot of our older homes are we going to
be setting up programs for owners of
those properties to Abate their lead
yeah that's what sb247 did do that I
don't remember all those details I
didn't have time to dig it up but it it
did create um funding to help with uh
loans for abatement for both uh owners
of rental units and I think also for
private individuals I think if both
those were included that was actually
one of the major thrusts of the bill was
not just to identify but to address the
problem in terms of the housing stock
because again we have the oldest housing
stock in the
nation any other questions of
Representative
kerk
thank you and I'm sorry I didn't already
address you
before uh uh we learned on one of the
bills lead bills we learned that we had
a high source of lead in the children's
water coolers at school so is that being
worked
on that's separate and I do not
recall again HHS will probably because
this is what they do we'll probably have
better detail about how that was
addressed but I do remember that was an
issue because it doesn't you have the
kids have exposure both uh at home and
at
school thank
you thank you representative kerk the
chair calls now on Nick Norman from the
apartment association of New
Hampshire thank you Mr
Norman thank you for having me speak
today so I I don't have a lot of
testimony to prepare are prepared for
this but I want to bring out one point
and I have emailed this testimony to you
very early this morning so if you check
your email it's there over here that
using that technology which is the the
rule and law now will keep the
environment safe and it's reasonably
easy to accomplish using RRP technology
abatement so uh someone also asked about
testing of lead in water in schools that
is part of the last lead commission that
we we're in and there is a bill in this
season on testing of water and lead in
schools or dick airs or something like
that you'll see it come up and I would
be extremely happy to take any question
if people are interested in what
landlords think or how we weigh in on
this any questions from Mr Norman
represent and lead poisoning prevention
program is responsible for implementing
RSA 13A the paint poisoning prevention
and control law which is in place to
identify and to provide services to
children in New Hampshire who have
elevated blood lead levels the healthy
homes and lead poisoning prevention
program oversees our state's blood lead
surveillance system and provides nurse
case management and environmental
investigation to families with children
72 months and younger that have elevated
blood levels I would like to thank the
committee for the opportunity to speak
today and I want to thank the sponsors
of this bill for their interested in
uh more cases and
therefore uh and because the testing is
already reported by the Laboratories the
the tests would be reported to the state
but it would be another impetus and
reminder for a parent about the need for
recording would that
be okay with the
Department um just to make sure I
understood the question so I I I believe
what you said is would we be more
amendable too if the language in the
bill did not have the reporting
requirement from the daycares or the
schools back to the department it would
impact certainly impact the um uh
Appropriations needed uh for the
Department to establish those secure
networks um and a database but there are
other elements in the bill that still
require the department to do certain
things like report back out in publicly
um reported uh uh reports there's also
language in there about um entry into
child care facilities and also reporting
from health care providers so um
certainly if there's an amendment to the
bill the department would be happy to
sponsor thank you
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chair and thank you both for taking my
questions um I understand that there is
this cost of implementation at the
department um do you think that the cost
of implementation at our child care
providers would be another burden that
might hurt our expansion of child care
options and do you think the cost of
implementation at the schools would be
mandate
um
I can't speak uh directly but I my
understanding is that it does create a
burden for the child care sector and the
well representative gay thank you thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
questions which is it's kind of like a
double barrel question what would be
your favorite thing to do that you think
would address the
address this issue um and what would you
think about my idea is that it's it's
better to do a full press trying to get
people aware of the problem just like
tobacco was attacked you know there was
a full press effort it was a cultural
thing uh so that and so I'm I'm feeling
torn between we have to prevent so we
really need to encourage people people
to remove the lead but then we ought to
be testing so that people who find out
oh my gosh my ground is you know it's
not just the walls and the doors but I
have to be careful about outside too so
I I'm all for the testing and all I can
think is that when I was a little kid
about a hundred years ago we went and
got our shots we all knew about the
shots and we all went down to the center
in town there was a public health center
and got them there and so it's kind of
like educate people the parents take
them and you have well in those days we
didn't have mobile units of anything but
if we had a mobile unit that could go
from down to town and here's your here's
your date we're going to be here these
two days I'm envisioning that being the
most coste effective way to do
testing uh but if please respond to that
question sorry I'll
stop sure I'll try so I mean this I I
think you're right that it is a a a
two-part approach to intervention you
have your prevention which is your
primary source of prevent you know let's
let's get the lead out um and and also
uh to educate and to test and to treat
if necessary so if kids have elevated
blood levels you want to you want to
find out about that early on and you
want to treat and and and remove those
um Hazard exposures so and as Beverly
alluded to before um the state has uh
processes in place uh to encourage or
increase testing rates in New Hampshire
unfortunately the pandemic has created a
a little blip if you will we were seeing
increased rates of uh you know lead lead
testing occurring but I I do believe the
pandemic has impacted that and and
that's actually uh something that's been
seen nationally that's not just a New
Hampshire situation is that kids aren't
getting to their provider offices soon
enough um be due to the pandemic issues
so we're hoping that we our our work
will continue forward and we'll still
see that once we get beyond the pandemic
that we'll see those lead testing rates
continue to in increase because that's
that's our what our focus is and our
work is at the department thank you very
much I just want to remind those who
have been using the amendment word
that this is an early Bill and has to
vacate this committee uh before the
first half of February so if you any of
you wish to work on amendments on this
with anybody else uh that's the deadline
so yes representative Weber thank you
just quick chair am I right in thinking
that this would go to finance as a
second committee yes it is thank you and
with that we close the hearing on House
Bill
1642 FN thank you all Mr chair may I
just actually make one positive comment
about something uh
well no oh sorry I wanted to just I know
what you wanted to do no no no sorry no
no that's you don't know I don't no well
I'm still going to say no but thank you
that's fine all right opening up now the
hearing on House Bill 1334 relative to
the definition of
vaccination I received an email from
representative
coma who said she will not be present
today and also recommends now we itl
this bill we still have to have a
hearing and I really truly hope no one
speaks to this because the sponsors
already said itl the bill and we know
that this happens because we're remember
we put all these things together last
summer turned them in they became bills
times changed we've learned new things
so it's no disgrace whatever for a
sponsor and we cannot withdraw the bill
but we can itl it which is what she
request are there any pink cards on this
no nothing is there anyone who wishes to
speak no
yes and the chair will entertain because
I have four minutes to kill uh the chair
will entertain a motion representative
Solway thank you Mr chairman I would
like to move itl on Miss Bill moves itl
second I closed the hearing on
1334 I'm now opening the exec session on
1334 and this is why you get the big
bucks thank
you and uh representative just so
there's no question make your motion
again
please thank you do I have a second
representative
Le
discussion would the chair ask the
clerk would the clerk please
call
the
role thank you Mr chair the question is
uh to
itl uh bill
number um 1334 1334 I was not ready for
a vote
sorry okay
um representative Leon yes
representative
McMahon representative representative
McMahon is absent today with
excuse uh representative Acton yes
representative gay representative
kushman yes representative fulam yes
representative Kelsey yes representative
King yes representative coal yes
representative delus and she is absent
delus also absent with
excuse uh representative Weber yes
representative McKay representative
Murray yes representative kerk yes
representative Solway yes representative
Canon yes representative nut upam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Woods yes representative
Merchant yes and representative Pearson
yes it's 19 yes to 19 to zero I trust
there's no objection to consent
you and the chair would like to welcome
because I have 30 seconds and I like to
do these things welcome uh
representative Murray what committee are
you here
from
thank you for the welcome I'm from
environment and agriculture good well
welcome to the best Committee in the
welome
1334 executive session is
over now I open the hearing on rep on
Bill 1244 local relative to parental
consent to medical and dental treatments
of children in schools and we call on
our very own representative kushman to
bills thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the
committee I bring to you today HB
1244 this bill seeks to insert in
statute a requirement That explicit
written consent from a child's parent or
Guardian be given in order for the child
to receive medical or dental treatments
in schools while DHHS does have guidance
that states two patient identifiers
should be checked and that a consent
form should be signed before a child can
participate in covid-19 vaccination
clinics it is only
guidance does the DHHS guidance document
carry the weight of law uh what are the
penalties for deviating from this
Guidance the word guidance implies that
that these are not rules but guidelines
and theoretically a school could adopt a
policy of opt out or implied
consent the World Health Organization
defines implied consent as follows a
process by which parents are informed of
imminent vaccination through social
mobilization and communication
communication sometimes including
letters directly addressed to the
parents subsequently the physical
presence of the child or adolescent with
or without an accompanying parent at the
vaccination session is considered to
imply
consent this practice is based on the
opt out principle and parents who do not
consent to vaccination are expected
implicitly to take steps to ensure that
their child or adolescent does not
participate in the vaccination session
this may include not letting the child
or adolescent attend school on a
vaccination day if vaccine delivery
occurs through schools so the World
Health Organization actually used this
consent process in randomized cluster
trials for a malaria vaccine um on
720,000 children in Africa and actually
in all of its um expanded program on
immunization trials it uses that um opt
out consent process um and it has
received significant backlash for that
um there were some articles in the
British medical journal um some going
back and forth so in New Hampshire the
optout standard that the wh uses in its
vaccine research won do we need to
ensure that no family's rights are
violated and no child receives any
medical or dental treatments for which
their parents have not given Express
consent we must ensure that um there are
no opt out consent processes being used
here and it needs to be in statute not
only in guidelines um it's a simple
Common Sense bill for our state and I
thank you Mr chairman again and members
of the committee and I ask you to
support this and give it an OTP thank
you thank you any questions for
representative kushman from the
committee representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for um uh bringing the bill and
taking my question because I hadn't any
idea that wasn't already in statute um
my question is and it may be for you or
it may be from somebody from DHHS so I'm
putting it out there for
everybody if the intent as it appears to
be is to
require um participa consent for all
participation in medical and dental
procedures that might happen at a school
uh is bury kind of burying it in the
children's oral health initiative the
right place to give
everybody notice that this is a
requirement not simply for oral health
programs but for any
program and the corollary to that is if
we were to find a
more um Global placement for the
provision uh would you want to put in an
exception for emergency care which
doesn't seem to be an exception at the
moment but certainly if if a child is in
extreme
distress the the usual procedure is to
treat first and and make the child safe
afterwards um thank you for your
question I don't believe that the
department administers any
emergency treatment per se I mean School
nurses maybe to stabilize a child sure
before an ambulance gets there um but
the way I read it it it's it's programs
administered by the department and and
section one is outside of the children's
oral health initiative um
statute so I think that addresses the
first question that you had okay um but
yeah I mean if we need to dig in and
just see if it's in the right place in
statute we can look at it closer um but
I will defer to DHHS on on the emergency
treatment if there's any conflict with
that representative I read in line five
medical or dental mhm but then I read in
916 bold italics a change oral health
only correct I'm I'm help me on this
because I see a disconnect so it's two
different sections in statute so they
okay um the first one
is um I'd have to look at the root
statute for that one 126a it has to do
with schools in general okay um and then
the bottom one is the oral health
initiative that's why it only refers to
Dental in that paragraph should I infer
then from line five that medical or
dental treatment is all already requires
explicit consent because it's not in
section okay they don't yeah they I get
it now thank you everybody
any qu any further questions for
representative uh representative Leo um
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative uh when you when you
looked at the Statue and looked at this
um it appears to me that you're talking
about programs administered by the
department which seems distinct from the
nursing programs that are administered
by the school and the SAU I know I dealt
with School nurses quite a bit on my
previous committee um is that something
where where you have the belief that
these programs administered by the
department are distinct from from those
care yes that was my
impression um the vaccine clinics are
and the the oral health initiative
clinics they're under
you representative gay thank you for
taking my question is there any way uh I
guess this is followup to the other
representative's question about making
this more global is there any way uh do
you have a problem with mentioning it in
multiple places in the rsas rather than
just one place uh and this seems like a
really good place to start uh but again
I'm I'm questioning on line four do we
have to just
say uh refer to DHHS rules because I
don't care what rules are I would want
medical or dental care in a school to
require uh author you know a parental
approval so should we put a an extra
phrase in
there on line four thank you for your
question Global yeah I I totally would
not be against doing that just to make
sure it applies to any programs admin
administered to school that is the you
know the purpose of the bill any any
medical or dental treatments besides
emergency um that there would need to be
explicit consent before those can be
administered follow up follow up would
it change would would we meet that
without adding a whole bunch of words
simply by changing the word on line four
instead of administered by the
school yeah I think just by getting yeah
Crossing out by the department any
program that provides metal medical or
dental treatment in a school setting
yeah shall require
y I saw representative Merchants hand
first and then representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman and also
thank representative for taking my
question I noticed in the line
16 it says any
school however if you go back to line
five it says a school so we talk about
all schools like we're doing in line 16
private um yes it would be I mean that's
the intention I don't see too much
conflict with that there when if it was
applied but so would you be comfortable
by inserting the board any yeah in line
five thank you yes thank
you representative
Shiro thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question um
online 9 five it refers to medical or
dental treatment I know in my community
um we have um Dental screenings for
students in school
um I don't think that would be
considered treatment although it often
leads to referrals to treatment um would
this consent um be
needed based on your bill to have those
Dental
screenings thank you for your question
and or Vision screen for that matter
thank you or scoliosis screenings you
rais a really good point um and I and
I'm glad you brought it up um I don't
think that it would and there have been
scenarios where an optin um to an opin
process for screenings have resulted in
lawsuits and so in the interest of
protecting the kids and the parents and
the schools it would probably be good to
representative thank you representative
kushman the chair now calls on
representative Judy Aaron who wishes to
[Music]
Bill thank you Mr chair good morning Mr
chair and good morning committee um I'm
here today to support this bill and I
really really appreciate how you're word
crafting this this is wonderful that
that you are all working together to
really uh make this
bill do what it's supposed to
do it's a pretty basic Bill and a pretty
clear that no medical procedures or
medical treatment or medical screening
now that you've brought that point up
should be done to any child without a um
explicit uh cons sent from the parent or
legal guardian that's the way it should
be
and I believe
that every single one of us here whose
parent who has had a child in school
would be mortified if something uh was
done to our child in school uh regarding
their medical treatment without our
knowledge we are the ones ultimately who
care for these children our children
and if something goes wrong uh as a
result of the treatment that's given in
school without our consent we are the
ones that have to deal with it and take
care of
it and that's something very very
important we have to keep in mind yes we
want to keep our children healthy and in
school it's a good place to see where
you know uh you know everybody is
congregated there already it maybe made
makes it easy uh certain screening
appointments Health appointments
whatever
it it can be done there in
schools that's a
convenience um but by the same token
parents should be made aware and be
given um they not be given but they they
have the right to uh opt their have
their child you know give consent to
what happens to their child during the
school day so with that I I really
appreciate all of you working together
to get this kind of language into
statute it's very important and I
appreciate your time to do this thank
you any questions for representative
Aaron representative kerk yes thank you
for taking my question um I wanted to
reflect back onto that question of
screening because the comment you used
is doing something to our kids and the
risk involved and I appreciate that in
terms of actually providing a treatment
but a screening is uh I can't think of
anything the screenings that we do such
as Vision or scoliosis screening or
hearing screening that has any risk and
we're not doing something to the child
so I wonder why we would want to
prohibit uh the screening without
permission well perhaps parent might not
want their child screened for
certain procedures or you know certain
health issues for whatever reason
maybe I don't know you can ask it would
be up to the parent I would imagine to
uh to decide whether they want their
not thank
you any other questions for
representative Aaron representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman and also
thank representative Pi the question
um this really deals with routine but it
doesn't say that explicitly my concern
is if a school nurse needs to treat a
patient in an emergency without the
consent they have to use an EpiPen
because of a penut allergy and so forth
is that going to preclude the nurse from
doing that or do we call the parent
first to get permission and wait for the
child I would imagine that the parent
already has something in
writing in with regard to allergies in
in the schools that that that wouldn't
come up as a problem followup please
follow up um yes it may be noted in the
chart of the child the allergy however
the consent for treatment may not be
there I don't know that that would be an
issue that would come up if if if my
child has an allergy of some sort and I
leave an EpiPen with the school
nurse without I'm I'm sure that there's
going to be some sort of consent along
with it to use it if in an
emergency my suggestion is as the
amendment is being crafted these various
uh suggestions will be taken to mind and
heart but thank you for raising them
list representative Leon uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative um
I'm not sure have you seen um some of
the news articles about some genital
screening of girls where one of the
school nurses actually did invasive
screenings for them and their parents
were not
notified I have and it's uh pretty
pretty horrifying that a parent would
not be aware of that kind of screening
going
on thank
you anyone else for the
representative thank you representative
the chair calls representative Al Bal
DeSaro with great appreciation sir from
coming back from Florida for today thank
you thank
you well I haven't I haven't made it to
Florida yet my wife's down there
actually okay but anyways for the record
representative Al baldau Rockingham
County District live which is uh
London um when I read the email that uh
representative kushman put out I was
kind of surprised that because i' saying
I'm a father of seven children four step
kids 13 grandkids and I always thought
it was already in school I didn't know
it was just a rule because I was one who
pushed for many years and my kids gone
to schools all around the country but
unfortunate out of uh five or six kids
gone here in New Hampshire uh five of
degrees uh M Bachelors you know when two
have Masters one went in the Marines so
New Hampshire schools have done well for
my children but we've gone to schools
all around the country and we made damn
well sure parental notification was
involved in anything my kids went to
school for an education they didn't go
there for a physical by nurses or
genital checks or anything like that
that's none of their damn business
business that's the parents business
I've written uh one of my sons had
headaches and here and there and I have
written letters just to give them
aspirin to nurse so any type of
screening um whether it be Dental or
anything should have parental permission
now you talk about emergencies what to
do there's no doubt in my mind parents
here whether it be epid needles or
aspirins or any type of you know um
Psychopathic drugs that they're required
to take during the day or there's
there's letters you're required to
submit a letter so there should be no
difference here and I'm speaking as a
father you know and have grandkids in
the school systems here that if you're
going to put in for emergency Define
what an emergency
is okay because otherwise that word will
be
abused right uh we send our kids for an
education not for a physical and I thank
you and that's all I have and that's why
I was pretty motivated that uh
representative kushman put this bill in
because it's a no-brainer it's a fixed
something that should have been put in
law a long time ago and I thank you
would you take any questions
representative anything for
representative
bazaro seeing none thank you sir that
was simple thank
you chair recognizes representative
Linda
camarada
good morning everyone honorable Linda
camarada serving 2018 to 2020 on
children and family law committee um I'm
here wearing all my hats today I'm a
parent um I'm a former Schoolboard me uh
member I'm a registered
nurse I did School nursing at an inner
city school two schools in
Manchester and um I taught Health
Professions to high school students for
17 years in Manchester today on this
bill um I love I want to uh Echo what
rep Aaron said about the way that you're
word crafting it I know from experience
how difficult it is to make it concise
so that there's no misunderstandings and
we don't have to redo and do and redo so
I appreciate that um I really want to
say that when I was school nursing and
my entire nursing career the most
important thing for us as healthc Care
Professionals is to follow the law
respect parents protect children's
rights and um this bill I also Echo rap
baldasaro that this should have been in
place a long time
ago we as nurses should not be doing
anything that a parent is unaware of so
when I did um hearing tests vision
screening scoliosis testing we number
one sent out notices that the child
needs to wear a bathing suit top so that
we could do scoliosis treatment um
screening excuse me we wanted them to
know we were doing Vision because they
needed their glasses if they came
without their glasses I couldn't test
their vision and for hearing if they had
just had a
cold or have a cold I can't do their
hearing because they can't hear when
they have fluid in their station too so
there's School nurses are overworked you
know that underpaid I used to call it
volunteer work because I made $11 an
hour but it was I loved that work so I
really didn't care yeah I I love
volunteering so
um paperwork is a pain in the neck what
we would do in schools even through my
high school um teaching is we would have
a list of permission forms at the
beginning of a school year these are the
movies we show in the classroom this is
what the school nurse does throughout
the year you'll be told a week in
advance that this needs to be done so
that preparation can be made so one of
my inner School inner city schools had a
health clinic incorporated into the
building because we had underserved
children extremely underserved children
and parents had trouble getting
transportation to go to the primary or
to the dentist so we welcomed certain
things um at that time it was we made
sure they had breakfast and
lunch sometimes we made sure they had
dinner um
but
we wanted to make
sure
that I want to F finish my thought with
we only did Dental we had the manest
Health Department dental hygienists come
in and with prior
notice um they would set up in the
atrium their equipment and the children
were all prepped and they got sunglasses
and fun things and we determined who
might need a referral who might have an
absess who can't concentrate in the
classroom so parents should I'll make it
shorter parents should be aware of
what's happening in your schools and
that it should be written um consent can
a lot of it can be done at the beginning
of the year and um it's important for
parents to protect their kids and to
teach them and teachers and nurses that
this is a minimal requirement the
parents know what's happening with their
kids I would entertain any questions any
questions for representative
camarada seeing none thank you so much
volunteering and the final pink card I
have is from rusen Chester from
herself we're getting a bit of feedback
excuse me would you hang on for one
second because we want to hear you but
other microphones are on and that's
system you may now proceed thank you
russan it's spelled r USU SS
an um russan Chester Bedford New
Hampshire I'm a former uh State of New
Hampshire employee and uh I've worked
with many um children school systems um
and
um disabled adults and um the one thing
that I can speak to is that I too was
surprised This was um already not in
place when I worked for the State of New
Hampshire I'm pretty sure that we fought
the Department of Health and Human
Services actually fought to put
something like this in place
specifically because we had a child who
um was um
significantly easily
overstimulated and some of the
screenings were problematic the parent
was not notified um prior to the
screening and then the parent had to
deal with the Fallout so that alone
should tell us even something as simple
as screening needs to be a parental
consent how the schools most of the
schools now if you need to bring an
EpiPen to school or um if you want your
child to be able to have Tylenol if they
if they say they they they have a
headache or something like that there is
something that the school can do at the
beginning of the year with whatever
they're bringing in to say I'm giving
parental consent that allows the nurse
um or anyone else in the school to not
have to go and check because it's with
the it's it's already there do I have
parental consent to to work with this
this child um so I'm coming from a
little bit different point I did want to
talk to two things regarding treatment
and screening no risk I spoke a little
bit about how screening can be risk um
maybe not in in all cases physically but
um emotionally and
psychosocial um so that's important and
um routine uh I actually spoke with that
spoke to that too is that it may be in
the child's chart but it's but the
consent may not be there the schools if
they are have anything for any child
that consent for that specific thing has
to be with the item um and um it this
this bill would allow
uh the schools to have less liability
over
um having treating children because the
consent would already be there or not be
there it also would allow parents not to
feel like they shouldn't send their
child to school on any given day because
they heard that they're going to be
doing the screening today so that's mine
question I know I was the
person thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I know I was the
representative that brought up the
question of screening
um however I'm struggling with the idea
of needing consent for screenings and
you use the example of someone who was
um easily overstimulated and had some
kind of screening and that led to um
problems but how would that be different
than um asking a student to participate
in anything in school um asking them to
do do
their um math work or something else um
a child who could be easily
overstimulated
by a screening could be easily
overstimulated by any request of a a
school staff and that is um why we have
Professionals in
school so I I guess my question is how
would you distinguish between a
screening and other requests of
students so with with regards to
overstimulation and during the Academia
portion of a child's um education that's
what the 504s and the IEPs are in place
for bottom line um we don't have that
for our administrative folks or our
nurses we don't have that kind of thing
well a little bit with the
administrative folks but with the nurses
specifically with regards to medical
dental vision all that type of thing we
currently don't have that kind of
protection in place for for those um
people within our school system they're
aware of the 504 they're aware of the
IEP it doesn't necessarily mean that
they know that uh scoliosis screening is
going to send that kid right off the
charts because of uh past history of um
something that the school was not aware
business thank
you any further questions thank thank
you so much for
coming the final pink card I have is um
from councelor robberry and councelor
John
Williams from
DHHS chairman Pearson good morning uh my
name is John Williams I'm the director
of legislative affairs for the
Department of Health and services and
I'm privileged to have attorney Rob
Barry who is General Counsel Rob Barry
it's I thought I was projecting well um
attorney Rob Barry who is General
Counsel and also legislatively aison for
our division of Medicaid services um the
insightful commentary the reason why we
felt the need to putting in the pink
card was to at least offer some
assistance and agreement in thanks to uh
representative gay represent Leon and
also represent Weber uh uh as to their
insightful observations that this bill
doesn't just touch upon Medicaid but
rather I think there's a larger
population that the bill sponsor would
like to capture under this bill um so
our suggestion we are here as a resource
to you um uh and also I would make
mention that this bill actually would
either be in co- jurisdiction with the
Department of Education or perhaps even
more prominently with the Department of
Education versus the Department of
Health and services so attorney Barry
caught one potential scrier error uh
that you'll find on line two of the bill
and it makes a reference to inserting a
new paragraph after
Roman 16 l case a Roman 16 lower case a
a quick review of the rsas shows that
there is no RSA uh that is uh 16a so you
would need to just re reumer that to
being uh Roman 16 which is repealed but
by the way that the drafting Attorneys
at the office of legislative Services
would handle it they would have then the
new paragraph being uh 16 lowercase a if
that makes sense to anybody but
represent Weber and myself and
so uh next uh at the very bottom where
uh and this is really kind of the whole
purpose I believe from repr kushman
embedded in the next section uh relative
to the Bold italic language relative to
parental consent written parental
consent um if you are to look at the
Department of Education statutes and
find an appropriate location within that
perhaps what you could do is take this
language and cross reference it back to
the Department of Education statute
making it very clear that the universe
that you're looking at is not just
restricted to those under the Medicaid
Program and so with that I offer
ourselves as a resource resource to you
on at least a procedural pieces of this
if you have any questions clinically Dr
Sarah finny who is our Dental Medicaid
director um Dr Finny was not coming here
today because the goal here today was
looking at specifically the issues not
clinical but rather the issue around
parental consent and we felt that
attorney Barry and perhaps myself could
help assist the committee in in drafting
in that respect but if there are
clinical questions for the Department
certainly she is available uh to having
a conversation with this committee
finally uh attorney Diana Fenton and
that's Fen t n Feen T and I see head
shaking yes she is essentially my
counterpart with the Department of
Education she did give her regrets of
not being here today and she actually
contacted our agency to ask if we would
at least report back to her on any
requests from from this committee so we
will make her aware that uh this
committee would be reaching out to her
potentially for an amendment to this
legislation to make sure that it is in
the appropriate location within the
Department of Education statutes and
with that that's probably the briefest
testimony for those of you who know me
and for those you who don't know me that
was a concise testimony on my part thank
do and we will take any questions but I
can see we're probably good to go thank
you thank you so much and since there
are no more pink cards and no hands up I
now close the hearing on House Bill
1244 local and we will be looking
forward to a wonderful Amendment coming
to us so we can exec the bill I open now
the hearing on House Bill
1466 relative to the off label use of
prescription drugs and relative to
Pharmacy prescriptions and the chair
recognizes representative canac cross
the prime sponsor to present your
thank you representative into to the
sorry I'm here today to speak about
House Bill
1466 I did write a little blurb
up I apologize about my voice as well I
weekend a physician's practice and
choices for prescribing is based in
science and knowledge as patients we
trust their clinical judgment and that
they follow a code of medical
ethics what is prescribed should be
between the prescriber and patient not
the pharmacist government Etc many
medications have been used for off label
use and will continue to be used when a
medication is used off label it means
that the medication has been FDA
approved for safety but not necessarily
for what it was originally intended
for um there are also many medications
that are used safely in other countries
that we do not have access to here in
ours and we should not change that now
due to certain things being
politicized a few examples are Calis and
Viagra it was originally used for
circulation uh Topamax
was um for seizures but it's now used
for headaches and sometimes an appetite
Weber thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
representative for taking my question I
just had a question about the language
on line 14 of the bill where it says no
licensed pharmacist shall face
non-disciplinary or disciplinary action
for ing a valid prescription for off
wondering it's it's also the
non-disciplinary action is also referred
to on line seven and I'm wondering what
is um I believe it's
just being spoken to
by the company
or you know whoever is in charge of them
Etc representative kerk thank you very
much for taking my question I have a
question about whether you would be
amendable to what I think would be a
friendly Amendment for
clarification in line uh line six and
sorry five and six you comment about uh
use off label when it's based upon sound
scientific evidence or sound medical
opinion agree with that below you have
these exemptions uh exceptions I should
say that there be no disciplinary action
unless the manufacturer specified the
hazard for that use or the license he
misled would you be amendable to adding
your language above and adding as a
third condition where a person can still
be disciplined being that if sound
scientific evidence and sound medical
opinion did not support this specific
off laal use by that license in other
words just reflecting your language
because you're do give that as a
qualifier for what makes sense why do we
why would we not have that down below as
something that would be an
exception yeah we will look into that
thank
you uh representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and thank
you representa for taking my question a
follow up on representative Weber's
question um would you be comfortable
putting the
word on line
15 action by the Board of
Pharmacy versus I think once we get into
the employer employee relationship
I know that Family Practice providers
may not prescribe certain medicines
without a special
license would this bill remove
that
Solway would you speak into the
microphone please for the
elderly sorry Mr chairman I'm a little
hard of hearing
what um uh representative kerk has
mentioned the wording on lines five and
six uh when such use is based upon sound
scientific evidence or sound medical
opinion it are is there an assumption
that the
FDA bases its decisions on something
other than sound scientific evidence
evidence or sound medical
[Music]
opinion I don't believe so no so there
is some standard other than fda's review
of um sound scientific evidence or sound
medical
opinion okay um I'm not quite sure what
you're asking to be
honest um it was my naive view that the
FDA made its decisions based on sound
scientific evidence or sound medical
opinion and I want to know if this is
that
no a quick followup followup Mr
chairman quick followup followup yes
thank um thank you representative cross
thank you for your patience with me
um I is there a procedure within
hospitals medical centers and research
organizations and IRB approval that can
in fact approve off Lael use I'll have
to get back to you with that I I asked
the question representative because
having served for many many many years
on irbs it was not uncommon for such
request to come before us okay thank you
for the information thank you thank you
Mr chairman representative gay thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question uh for the record I fully uh
support the intent of this bill but I
think uh when such use is lines five and
six when such use is based upon sound
scientific evidence and sound medical
opinion is a complicating Factor here
because when you have people of great
experience who disagree with each other
that that would mean that you could not
use uh off-label drugs for new purposes
if some other sound medical people
disagreed so I would strike that because
we're right now in the middle of this
across the world and in our own country
we have people who are medical experts
who totally disagree and you could and
the problem is right now one side is
winning and the other side uh can't use
uh certain medications
for something that's never been tested
even though that very product I'm
talking about hydroxy chloroquin is used
profoundly in this country for an off
Lael purpose for ra and lupus uh so I'm
thinking that is a very
restrictive uh phrase when such use is
based upon sound scientific because you
never get to use something for a new
purpose if the people who you know other
medical experts disagreed
that I do understand what you're saying
as well but this would be based between
a provider and the patient so the
patient would
be trusting the sound medical advice of
that prescriber well that would be great
I'm sorry followup that would be great
to put that phrase in that is that Mak
makes really good sense that it's
patient any further questions for the
representative representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair question to
the representative we just talked about
informed consent um do you foresee a
need to have informed consent for off
label use or is that basically something
that is between the patient and the
prescriber verbally or do you want it
some sort of a
um ability for the patient to understand
the drug that's being prescribed is in
fact off label it's not something
indicated by the
FDA I do foresee that but I also know
that informed consent comes along with
patient and
prescriber
um I'm I trying to think of discretion
and when they're giving out medications
and you accept that medication a lot of
times informed
involved representative
Shapiro yes thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question um perhaps I
should know this but I don't um
currently are Physicians or pharmacists
being disciplined for using off off
I have heard of a few I don't personally
know but I could look into it more and
get back to
you thank
you representative gay one more that's
all I haven't figured out how to put
this in a form of a question um does
anybody else have a question while the
representatives is figuring out the
rules of Jeopardy have you got it ready
now so uh are you aware that Dr Simone
gold was fired after she prescribed
hydroxy chloroquin which had already
been treated people in SARS Co
1 yes I think that was one of the
Weber I beg your pardon so that brings
me to the question of that I think has
actually been raised before perhaps by
representative
Merchant about specific differences
between being disciplined by a
regulatory body for an off label use
versus not following the um requirements
of one's
employer for a use do you see that there
is a difference there between uh what a
regulatory board may do and what a an
employer or an organization who is
employing a particular person might
employment um I do believe that is a
hurdle that we could come
across
representative
McKay thank you Mr
chairman would you please define uh what
drugs when a prescription has been FDA
approved for safety but isn't used for
intention
followup I didn't understand the
said so there's been many medications
that have been researched and used for
one purpose but they find that it's
useful for another treatment for
something else so it's been an approved
for safety usage through the FDA but
they found that like hydroxy chloroquin
was originally used to treat malaria but
now they're using it for
much rep representative kerk um thank
you for taking my question I I guess I'm
still a little baffled by the inter
change earlier that sound opinion of the
provider because in general when we look
at the issue of gathering evidence for
any intervention treatment um technical
uh device whatever it's based upon not
just one opinion uh in in in our
literature and in our meetings we often
have fights over what the best treatment
for something is and people will differ
but then we try to reach a consensus
based upon best available scientific
evidence and no matter what it is some
people are going to disagree so if we
put in sound opinion of the provider
would that not just basically open the
door to anybody doing anything they
please without any super any any uh
oversight
whatsoever um I'm happy to look at the
you thank you for coming before us
today the chair recognizes
representative Erica Leon she wants to
speak for three
minutes
okay thank you Mr chairman and thank you
fellow members of Health and Human
Services I want to start off by thanking
representative cross for doing such an
amazing job this is the first time she's
been in person to a hearing and I think
that she did phenomenal with our new
situation and handling what is a very
stressful situation so I want to thank
her very much when
I look at my background I was a medical
device analyst for a very long time I
looked at regulatory approvals and when
you look at development of a
pharmaceutical or a device the company
looks to the first indication for that
they can have approved that first one
could be $10 million it could be $100
million it could be $300 million to get
that
approval if they find other uses that
have significant benefit have enough
benefit that it overcomes the risk
they're still not going to do a clinical
trial unless it's required for
reimbursement or unless there is enough
of a different use that they feel that
there's a need to really get that
approval over 20% I I've read over 20%
but in the past I've read a much higher
percentage of drugs are used off label
today right now it it it had not been
much of a concern in the past because we
didn't have this High highly politicized
situation where suddenly your choice of
medicine decides whether or not you're a
good person and it's really a shame
we've reached this point and I hope we
can back away from that Cliff um as we
look to all of these decisions and all
of this information off Lael medicine is
a little bit finding from the Nebraska
Attorney
General when he was asked about the off
use of off-label
drugs healthare providers do not violate
the standard of care when they select
between two reasonable reasonable
approaches to Medicine regulations also
indicate the physicians may utilize
reasonable investigative or unproven
therapies that reflect a reasonable
approach to medicine so long as
Physicians obtain written informed
patient consent informed consent
concerns a doctor duty to inform his or
her patient and it includes telling
patients about the true nature of the
pertinent ailment or condition the risks
of proposed treatment or procedure and
the risks of any alternative methods of
treatment including the risks of failing
to undergo any treatment at
all so this brings to the question of do
we want an amendment that says that
there needs to be written informed
consent because if we do that we have to
look at what's the approval for aspirin
if we're going to tell a patient that
they should be using it for fever
reduction or if we should be using it
for blood pressure where there's not an
approval for blood pressure do we want
that paper trail I think that having a
strong indication that in controversial
cases or in something where there's not
a strong body of evidence it might be
prudent for that doctor to have in have
written informed consent but a solid
discussion documented in the in the
medical record between the patient and
the provider should be able to cover
mden if that's the path that you're
planning to take um I I respect your
opinion your experience with irbs
they're phenomenal when you're looking
at these really edge cases when it comes
time to look at something where there is
no evidence and there are no data that's
when we really need to step back and
make sure that there's a large group of
professionals who are reviewing whether
or not this is a prudent step as we
start to collect data as we start to
have information we get to a point where
reasonable people can disagree and
reasonable people can take a different
path um as we do that we get that Wild
and Woolly practice of medicine that
happens as we try and find out what's
best we can't have consensus until we
have people practicing medicine working
with their patients for their best
absolutely unheard of the idea a of
doing anti-coagulation therapy for a
drug alluding stent after six months was
heresy but then we found out about late
stent
thrombosis um what I want to make sure
we do is that we protect the practice of
medicine and we make sure that doctors
aren't going to be disciplined for
political reasons we need to go back to
the way that we used to work and make
sure that Physicians are free to talk
with their patients and find a solution
to improve their health outcomes thank
you
any
questions representative
um just speaking from a personal
question here uh I currently am on two
off label
drugs uh do I run the risk of some point
one of them possibly getting
political and and having to go off of it
even though it has been successfully
treating an off label use for five years
um thank you for that question I would
hope not um right now I think that a lot
of this is focused around ircon and
hydroxy chloroquin although we don't
know what might come to come to be
controversial in the future um you do
run the risk that if there are data
collected and we find that um like with
some with the the Radine one of the ones
for stomic acid that it actually causes
cancer there may be a need to find
another therapy but that would be
because data are available that show a
risk and practice changes whether it's
use representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking the question
patient from something that they should
be protected from how do we protect the
patient ultimately from a decision by a
practitioner that wasn't in the best
interest and that's try to get to is
that it's that's the underlying concern
is that when you get the off label use a
lot of it's okay probably 99% of it 1%
of it could be a problem so how do we
ultimately protect the
patient do you trust thank you for the
question and that is what becomes so
challenging when we're discussing these
things that are so highly charged um do
you trust the patient and the doctor to
have a discussion about the facts and
the data and to come to a conclusion or
do you feel that there needs to be
another person in the room with them
followup yes and no um having practiced
in Pharmacy and seeing many scripts
coming across my counter from some
practitioners that I questioned I would
say that there is a risk out there
although it's small that we should not
ignore and somewhere along the way the
patient should be somewhat protected and
I'm just concerned about that 1% how do
we protect the patient because it does
occur um thank you with with those
prescriptions was that an issue of
contraindications or risks or that sort
of problem or just a disagreement about
the treatment practice it was probably
more a disagreement on the treatment
practice but also when you go back to
look at opiate prescriptions right now
what's going on is that we have patients
that are coming to the pharmacy by
practitioners that to use their license
prescribe opiates in
un large amounts if you will but
someone's not protecting the patient
from opiate addiction so that's an
example I can use that's real life that
I do concern myself with is that there
are documented cases of prescribers that
have abused their licensing privileges
to make Financial
benefits and I'm just concerned about
that going on and not being somehow
contained um thank you um manipulating
reaction uh this is one of those areas
where the doctors used to prescribe
cigarettes for nausea for women in
pregnancy uh what we need to do is
instead of driving people underground
work to collect the data work to colle C
the information because if we're able to
look at something where people have have
data to point to for their use of a of a
medication off label if they have data
to point to them there should be some
collection of data it shouldn't be a
requirement of this because this is
individual practice that will largely be
H happening outside of the hospital
practices which have institutional
policies which likely will prohibit such
um prescriptions but we need to
encourage that collection of data so
that we can find out whether or not
there is harm and if the patient is part
of that part of the pursuit of using
some of these some of these things off
label in order to um improve their
health I don't think that it's the role
of the government to get in Signal which
opioids representative
Solway thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative uh just a quick question
uh on line six it states and therefore
the board shall not take disciplinary or
non-disciplinary remedial action does
this in any way protect practitioners
from civil
suits in the event that there is an
untoward effect of an off Lael
use I don't see any thank you for the
question I don't see any protection from
that because if they are using something
and if they' misled their patient um
having a good strong documentation about
their discussion of the risks and
benefits and the patients understanding
of the limitations of the data should
protect them which means that they need
to have a strong discussion with this
patient if you have a patient knocking
down your door asking for one of these
something off label they bear some of
the responsibility as well if you come
to a discussion on that and if they're
the one that bears the medical harm then
they are taking responsibility for that
harm um when when you look to the
disciplinary or non-disciplinary those
words are actually in the rules for the
licensing board and that's part that's
why the words of disciplinary or
non-disciplinary are in this uh in this
Bill thank you thank you representative
kerk thank you I'm uh still a little
baffled about how we Define this issue
of sound scientific evidence sound
medical opinion or I think you use the
word reasonable evidence um and this
kind of dubils into that question of
what what we expect people to do for an
informed consent if we talk about doing
that because you have to then give both
sides in a in a sense educate the person
as to the risks of each of those whether
you're going to use the off label or not
use the off label and what the opinion
is not just yours but the opinion of the
weight of scientific evidence we have um
H so this is kind of squishy and not
defined which so isn't that what the
role of the Board of Medicine would be
is to look at sure Board of anybody it
could be uh pas and so on to be able to
look at that question of did that person
follow what was sound evidence and not
just say it's the opinion of the
practitioner because that seems to be
what was being stated am I confused on
this
uh so what can I clarify that question
for you you're asking
if having if simply being able to point
to Scientific evidence or medical
opinion should be reason that they do
not are not subject to disciplinary
action um I'm sorry I did probably ask
that poorly um the bottom line is sort
of how do we Define what sound
scientific evidence or sound medical
opinion is
um it's not just what might be
reasonable to think of sometime but what
is the predominance of evidence that is
currently available and so I'm trying to
figure out how when we put some this in
statute we haven't defined how that's
determined
uh the if you start defining how it's
determined you're getting into issues
about requiring an informed consent form
for aspirin for blood thinning so we we
need to be careful about where those
educations are perhaps it's a matter of
having an amendment where in sub cases
of
controversy um the doctor must have
notes as to the points of evidence
referred to and the discussion with the
patient um because if they are
discussing the data that are available
there doesn't need to be consensus I'm
not sure I assume you're the American
Academy of orthopedic surgeons and the
swine surgeons I was shocked about how
many years it took for a new therapy to
make it into the consensus guidelines
sometimes that was eight years and think
about the lives that would be harmed if
you waited for consensus to come around
so we need to balance this in the
practice of medicine but I I do think
that um I believe uh representative
cross will agree with me that there's
some been really good points raised and
I think it's a matter of looking for
some amendments to clarify this but what
we need to do is make sure that we're
not stifling that practice of medicine
while also making sure that we're not
giving doctors a license to again
prescribe cigarettes for nausea and
pregnancy thank
you thank you so much for your testimony
the chair now calls James Stewart from
Rochester wave off thank you James
Stewart from
Rochester and you're a citizen and you
would like to speak to this bill in
favor of Welcome hi thank
you I'd like to speak a little less
intellectually or scientifically or
legislatively and speak more plainly
hopefully my diag log is a little more
plain
fear I can see some of you are wearing
masks and you're wearing masks because
you're trying to protect others etc etc
because you're afraid you're afraid of
Co the
media and various
politicians and the NIH and various
interests have made
it very easy for us to be
fearful we're afraid of
covid I have a cousin who died of covid
probably didn't have to my thought
is that the hospital protocol killed
him
well you saywell what are we to do well
first of all let's just admit there's
more and more evidence coming out around
the world folks around the world the
evidence is there if you look don't
listen to the popular media to the to
the letter
stations the covid shot which is a
genetic uh experimental genetic liquid
that they inject you allow them to
inject into you is not safe it is not
effective
well then what are we to do we must do
something you're trying to do something
everyone's probably do trying to do
something even if you're not wearing a
mask you're probably trying to do
something you you're using antibacterial
methods with your hands etc etc you're
distancing all like we want to do
something here's something we can do
doctors there's been times in the past
when we've bled people at some point
some doctors say no we can't do that
anymore it's harmful what if someone
came along and said no you must continue
to bleed them no you can't use
penicillin no aspirin is only for this
doctors are
doctors they sometimes use off Lael
drugs it's just the way it is doctors
around the world have discovered yes in
India where they they're destroying
covid by using
icin in Israel where they're finding
that I guess the shot or the booster or
the third booster or the fourth booster
like they're talking about six boosters
in the Netherlands right now do you know
that how effective it is a
vaccine that you need six boosters come
on let's admit it it's not safe it's not
effective we need something else maybe a
lot of something else and it's certainly
not M desia which killed my
friend about four weeks ago they denied
her Ivor mechon denied it the lady was
dying doesn't she get her
choice come on in enable people there
was some questions here about who gets
responsibility who gets the choice
people can do their D du diligence look
into it and choose for
themselves we are still Sovereign people
in this nation we don't tell other
people what they inject into their
bodies or what they cannot
use if you start doing that uh you're
going to be here not just for a couple
hours you're going to be here for days
months years because you have revamp the
entire system let people decide give
them the responsibility the doctor's
advise they decide give them
hey if you want to give them all the
information like inform formed consent
how about if we do that about the co
shot we're not doing that there's a lot
more to know about that Co shot than
people know it's being covered up by you
name it I can go down through the list
all the Medias the Twitter's the the the
the
politicians some doctors the NIH I mean
what why would fouchi want to cover this
up well he's the one who funded the NIH
who and he knows that they funded that
in Wuhan when this first happened I went
Wuhan I looked up on my phone I mean
it's obvious in Wuhan is a coron virus
research facility duh of course it came
from there didn't come some animal this
was UPF funded by Dr fouchy he wants to
cover this up he knows Ivon works ion
saves lives who are we to be telling
doctors who have
studied and people who also study as
individual Sovereign citizens of the
State of New Hampshire that they cannot
use
ion to save their life or the life of
their their loved one if they see their
loved one going down the path to death
don't they get to choose to try that if
we stop doctors from trying things like
that off label we're going to sever
the re part of the research that doctors
do in real life situations they discover
things and then it becomes known and
pretty soon it changes the way we look
at something and it saves
lives we need this we need these let's
just admit it this is mostly about
hydroxy chlorin chloroquin and
chloroquin and ican and there are some
others but doctors are afraid I talked
about fear initially doctors are
afraid and they don't want to go against
the protocol that it's given them from
up
above enable them to save lives that's
what they want to do Do no harm they
know that doing harm with we Desir and
some of the other things that they're
left with give them all the tools to
save lives don't deny them pass this
bill any questions thank you sir thank
you so much questions done a lot of res
resarch into this believe me thank
you so sitting here listening to all the
testimony I was wondering I just wanted
to ask everyone here who's not
supporting the bill why do doctors go to
medical school in full disclosure I'm a
paramedic critical care and flight
certified and fto training officer and
I've done training in EMT and paramedic
for about 10 years it's about as much
training as a PA roughly as far as all
the schooling and clinicals um so
technically the advanced provider um
doctors however go to school for longer
right they go to school for four years
four years of medical school
certifications and tests and uh
residency of between three and 8 years
or longer and maybe fellowships of
another I don't know 5 10 years so why
do they go through all that and finish
school at 40 with a half million dollars
of debt it's to learn medicine how to
treat patients appropriately right it's
not how to follow a cookbook even I can
follow a basic cookbook right so they go
to school for extra 20 30 years and give
up their lives and go into dep forever
to learn how to treat patients so I
think we should let them treat patients
instead of making them uh into cookbook
cookbook practitioners like you say in
medicine um um you call them like you
know textbook cookbook monkeys um I
think this bill at at its core is really
about do we want doctors to be follow a
cookbooks or allow them to use their
brains I know representative cross and
some others mentioned some off Lael uses
an off Lael like they mentioned is not
really a great term because it makes it
sound like it's kind of taken a risk and
there's no science or data uh supporting
a use of a certain medication they
brought up you know uh selenophile
phosph race 5 inhibitors for for Ed were
originally used for pulmonary
hypertension they Vis dilate then they
found obviously a tremendous side effect
that became more financially rewarding
business but it's not just that it's
there are tons of medications right now
I think representative Leon mentioned
maybe 20 30% of or more of medications
are used technically off label all off
Lael means by my understanding is the
FDA approves a drug and they approve it
the drug and for a specific use maybe
one use maybe multiple uses anytime a
doctor prescribes that to a patient
after examining them and getting to know
the patient personally and having a
discussion between a patient and a
doctor anytime he prescribes that
medication for anything besides for the
one specific use approved by the FDA
it's technically considered off Lael so
I just wanted to put it out there first
that off Lael doesn't mean crazy doctor
being a cowboy throwing random drugs at
a certain disease it means it's
literally not approved by the FDA for
that specific purpose but could be safe
um in an article I I wrote and I'll
submit this in the evidence I'll email
the committee um I think there were 70
studies or 100 studies of icin proving
it is safe and effective with uh Corona
virus hydroxy chloroquin I think also
100 over 100 studies proving it is safe
and effective of course both of those
drugs happen to have been approved by
the FDA um for other diseases not covid
but approved by the FDA as very safe
decades ago 50 80 100 years ago of
course they used hydroxy chloric wiin
and icin used all over the world from
Africa to India extremely safely safely
you know uh very very few negative side
effects um I I would say I I'm
supporting the bill and I'm asking the
committee to support the bill but with
an amendment I was thinking before and
I'm glad I think representative gay
mentioned it the part about being uh
sound medical judgment or sound uh
Medical Science and consensus has to be
stricken because unfortunately nowadays
maybe it wasn't like this 100 years ago
now it's all politicized if you ask
people on one side of the aisle they'll
say everon is safe and effective and of
course I have hundreds of stud need to
prove that if you ask people on another
side of an aisle they might say Aon is
the most dangerous substance in the
universe if you touch it you will die um
in fact the FDA themselves said you're
not a darn horse don't take icin it's
going to be dangerous for you don't take
it for Co so it's been politicized and
right now if this part remains in the
bill saying doctors can only approve
things or prescribe medications that are
you know with sound medical judgment who
would determine what the sound uh
medical judgment means it would be be
the FDA and the FDA has already made it
known that they believe everon is the
most dangerous substance in the universe
pretty much um so there goes that um as
far as one of the representatives on the
committee asked are doctor is it
currently happening yes I think I have
heard of doctors um being threatened by
the the AMA or other board certification
associations and I think some have lost
their licenses for not supporting um uh
not opposing and crushing everm dark
clor Quinn um I think some states
actually banned it I think New York
prevented an unprecedented tyrannical
move prevented doctors from prescribing
erectin andal chloroquin um to patients
with coron virus which again we should
not be getting between doctors and
patients and someone mentioned I think
earlier on the committee that you're
going to wrap it up now you asked for
three to five minutes and we got to move
on so let me give you one more minute
yes sir thank you um and and the final
point someone mentioned um should there
also be informed consent required and
are we worried about patients being
protected um nothing would change this
bill doesn't say doctors can kill
patients with without any repercussions
patients could still Sue so if I go to
my doctor have a discussion with him we
both agree econ is the right choice for
me or any drug for this exact purpose is
the right choice that's we agreed to it
we both have some responsibility if it
happens to be that drug kills me and
there was a contraindication I didn't
know about and the doctor didn't know
about what I should have I can still sue
him you know I could still bring him to
court for that and he could still be
punished criminally or Civ so this
wouldn't take away from that this
wouldn't necessarily get rid of all
repercussions um as far as a doctor
being punished for hurting a patient so
you seeing none thank you for your
testimony I saw representative G thank
you for your testimony I'll run the
kushman wave off thank
minutes morning again thank you Mr
chairman for the record I'm
representative Judy Aaron uh represent
Sullivan
7 and I live in the town of aworth um I
did send you written testimony via email
I'm not going to read it but what I want
to say is um very interesting discussion
on this uh piece proposed
legislation I think there are some uh
you know issues that need to be teased
out but bottom line is you know we
talked a lot
about physician uh pharmacies and
pharmacists that you know maybe afraid
of getting sued or malpractice suits or
whatever and trying to protect that 1%
from some doctor that might not be
helpful how about we also talk about
about all of
those people who were prescribed
medication went to the
pharmacist and couldn't get a
prescription
filled and then went home
empty-handed and proceeded to get worse
with their ill
illness we have to think there is a
balance here as representative L wisely
I think it's really a
shame that we can't seem to be providing
people who have prescription from their
doctor with the drugs that have been P
prescribed and what ultimately happens
is then you have a situation where black
markets emerge people are getting their
medication from places like Tractor
Supply
really is this is what we want I don't
think
so that's not the kind of medical care
that we should
be you know
that if a doctor prescribes a drug
biologic or
device that prescription should be
honored and that's really all I need I
came to say today is
I'm more worried about the people who
are being prescribed legitimate
medication from their legitimate
doctor and then being turned away from a
pharmacy because some for some reason
the pharmacy and pharmacist decide that
this is not the treatment that they
should be
getting I don't agree with that so thank
you for listening and I hope that you
will uh pass this bill with whatever
decide Kel representative
Kelsey thank you Mr chairman um would
you agree that this bill should be
amended to include all prescribers and
not only
Physicians I think that's a
you representative gay thank you for
taking my question and comment are you
aware that
um most pharmacies mostes at least in my
town I called every one of them and
every chain had forbidden them for
filling prescriptions for covid that
that uh were either icin or hydroxy
chloroquin I had heard of that everyone
I had heard of that that people were
getting prescriptions to be treated with
ior macton uh early on in their covid um
illness
and were denied when they went to the
pharmacist to have their prescription
filled they were denied so what are
these people are supposed to do um then
this is where we turn to black market
situations where people are getting
things and God knows what other things
they might be getting that they are not
prescribed by their
doctor followup one followup are you
aware the doctors are being told they
cannot my own said I can order it for
you that was in May but when my husband
got sick she couldn't she had been told
she couldn't I had heard of that too and
that's really pretty tragic it's a shame
and it's anyone else sorry sorry
continue representative I cut you off
I'm sorry I'm all good
thanks thank you for your testimony
appreciate it thank you very much
committee you're doing great
work chair recognizes rusen Chester one
to three minutes welcome back
we give Frequent Flyer points in this
place I'm going to be flying
often um my name is Russ anchester I'm a
resident of Bedford New Hampshire um
have been a resident of New Hampshire
since for 61 years I was prescribed an
off Market prescription uh three years
ago four years ago now um and when that
prescription became part of the
political profile I could no longer get
it and that was devastating um I had to
find Alternatives I worked very closely
with my physician to try and find the
Alternatives because initially my
physician was prescribing it and the
pharmacy wouldn't fill it now the
current problem is my physician has been
told by her employer that um they are
not to be Contin continuing that
prescription with me because it is an
off whatever um and
um that um she's not willing to at this
time leave her employment and she has
been told that prescribing that
prescription to me will um result in um
potentially her losing her license
additionally um I
have uh
I have a
um situation where my partner is
vaccinated I am not vaccinated I'm
vaccine injured not from covid but I
can't take the vaccine for covid because
of that um my partner less than 24 hours
after receiving his booster um was
hospitalized for three days we tried we
at well before the hospitalization 24
hours he started coming down with some
symptoms of covid-19 we asked for um ior
mechon and the various um other
opportunities and it was a Flatout no it
was actually said if you're experiencing
difficulties go to the emergency room um
which just is exactly the opposite of
what we should be doing we don't want to
overwhelm our hospitals and our doctors
are being told that's what they have to
say um I had the same experience I
developed covid um I chose to go to
tractor buy and other places to get what
I needed because I learned that in my
other off prescription drug it worked so
um I was willing to give it a try and uh
I but I had full for informed consent um
this is a problem that we're having now
is um doctors are fearful for their
license they're making it very clear my
doctor will not give me an exemption for
the covid-19 vaccine right now because
she is too afraid that she has been told
by her employer to a certain extent
unless I'm absolutely sure it'll kill
you I can't give you an exemption now
I'm vaccine injured I mean this is
important and this is now the vaccine is
just we're not talking about the vaccine
necessarily but it's all part of the
conclusion it's when
prescriptions become when medications
become politicized follow the money
there's a lot more money to be made in
all the all the ways that we're being
told to treat this than there are not
like I said my op prescription drug
never had a problem until
2021 thank you so much for your
testimony and the final pink card is
we're bringing back the honorable Linda
Bedford am I right in assuming you're a
nurse on RN yes sir okay thought
so thank you
chairman yes I'm back um I'm wearing my
RN hat and my patient hat my notes are
on here this is a very emotionally
charged testimony for me um I'm a
researcher
by Nature
and I've researched covid since the very
beginning I love um Public Health I love
data so there's good bad and ugly to
anything we have only heard one side of
the picture I think we all understand
that there's been
censorship I've lived I'm old enough
that I've lived through the swine flu in
the 70s and we had gilean Beret side
effects I've lived through the HIV AIDS
where in 1981 we had no idea what was
going on and it was very
politicized I've lived through mer
Middle Eastern uh respiratory zika Ebola
now
K2 off label prescriptions you've heard
already is very are very customary I'm
on one myself to Echo what the prior
speaker said um my supply of my off
label which I need to take was held up
because of the
politicization of this
illness as a registered nurse and
Physicians and pharmacist we do know
harm well there's a lot of harm that has
been done in the last 20
months and if you're paying attention
you already know that that something is
desperately a
mess we value our patient physician
relationship it is
Priceless and all of a sudden we aren't
giving our physicians due uh respect
they've gone to school for about 12
years um Physicians should and need
autonomy they don't want somebody over
their shoulder telling them how to
practice
medicine and my personal experience and
this is why it's emotional is I've had
the most wonderful physician primary
physician
for maybe 15 years maybe 20
he was like right out of school when I
first started working with him as my
physician
and I went for a physical in September
and I said to my wonderful
physician doc if I get sick with this
thing because time is I felt like my
time was running out then I'm next and I
looked him right in the eye and I adore
this physician he said if I get sick
with this are you you going to be able
to help me before I get in the hospital
are you going to be able to offer
treatment you going to be able to
prescribe ior meton and there was this
dead silence for about it felt like
forever but it was probably about 10
seconds he looked down no eye
contact looked up and said he couldn't
because his Association would take his
license I cannot look at my physician
anymore I don't even know if I can go
back to him because we had such a
fabulous relationship and I haven't been
able to deal with the idea that he's
lost track of his oath and his purpose
in being a physician so I ask that you
support this bill if it needs tweaking
tweak it as you are competent in doing
but we cannot be having big ENT entities
telling our physicians how to practice
medicine it destroys the patient
physician relationship and we are all
susceptable to learning what I learned
in
September and i' be happy to take any
questions I thank you all for your work
you're working very diligently I
appreciate it thank you thank you so
much and we will look forward to um if
you wish representative cross amendments
an amendment people that have said some
things that may strengthen the bill you
can come back with an amendment we're
going to hold on to it for a month or so
and with that uh the hearing on House
Bill 1466 is
concluded and we'll see you back around
lunch yeah I think you said before lunch
you
yeah I'm not I'm sorry I'm not springing
for lunch we'll see you after your lunch
prepared
sorry
you know a lot of this is the
politicization I remember as a kid I was
on a certain thing and was a combination
of our local Standalone Pharmacy
pharmacist and our family doctors you
know that might work and they tried it
it
worked see the problem NE we had aoke
Doctor Who thought he knew more than
everybody else and so he didn't just do
a wise
cautious asked a few other use of off
lab this guy was a
cowboy and so that has poisoned the well
to this idea down where I live because
I
this is where I hope our committee will
rise to our usual great thing of being
but
situ
you
might cover do you think that a
Solo solo employer or solo um attendant
provision might solve both of those
problems I can see where um article
three where they're talking about um why
uh a a customer not be allowed back for
the health and safety to the customer or
the shop
you representative gay thank you uh Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question like the handicap tags I don't
I don't know the proper term but you
know a car tag has an expiration date um
you either get a blue one that lasts
forever or you get a red one with the
dates put on it so I was just wondering
uh in order to pass this it's nice to
know what the cards have looked like
successfully in other states uh and do
they have an expiration like you're not
going to be pregnant forever but but
hope not oh my goodness but at certain
ages we would need the card forever so
uh that's what I was just
wondering uh I haven't seen one of the
cards I I'm hoping that someone who is
uh familiar with this perhaps the person
who requested this of me will be here
and can talk about that I think that's a
great idea checking with those other oh
I don't know 300 states that have
already done this and it's followup
followup so it's your medical provider
and I noticed that you did say you
didn't say doctor you said somewhere in
here it says a it's under three on the
last page okay but any
yeah I haven't found it yet but I trust
you that oh excuse me it's under it's
under uh one um when I first created
this I asked for all of the possible uh
cards that someone could use that can
certainly be narrowed down we can
certainly say it's it can only be from a
health provider and that the card has to
look like such and such or um I know the
National Organization for this for IBS
also um manages this really well we
should contact them and see if they've
got an idea but it's more than I'm sorry
followup followup one more but it does
cover this would cover many causes not
just Crohn's disease so it sounds
wouldn't it wouldn't it be more
reasonable to have the medical provider
figure out whether somebody needed it
and not have to justify which condition
made that absolutely your your medical
provider could could certainly make sure
that all of the requirements are filled
thank
you representative
fome thank you chairman Pearson and
thank you for bringing this bill um
having had lived with someone who had an
ostomy for many years and we did at
times have to go a panic to the counter
and say do you have a restroom
um he my former husband carried a a card
with him from UAA it was not signed by
any doctor um United ostomy Association
of America had a card and with that
little card he was never turned
away okay so we're not talking
about hard-hearted people or and there
was a time when one person said we've
got a bunch of stuff piled in the
bathroom just be really careful that you
don't knock anything over over or
whatever it was very much open and I'm
assuming I'm hoping that we have a
witness here today who can explain maybe
better to people what that situation is
like um so you haven't seen the UAA card
I I haven't I did a lot of research I uh
the PDF that I sent you has some
information like that in it I said it on
Friday from my ledge email followup um
uh one thing that could be recommended
is that an organization possibly like
UAA could Supply doctor's office with a
supply of these cards and the doctor can
just hand it to their patient and say
use this that's a great idea that is a
really great idea thank you
representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman and also
thank re for taking my question I'm sort
of nitpicking here but one of the things
that I'm always thinking about is how
something could be abused by the parties
that don't intend to do it appropriately
like the people with the handicap
stickers that President refer to online
if you look at it 26 a National
Association so if I have a card from my
Pharmacy Association does that
qualify if your Pharmacy Association is
being used for a a Crohn's visit but
what I'm saying is the law being what
what's written here it doesn't say that
so I'm just saying that possibly to
minimize abuse of it could we change or
clarify that the nation Association has
to come from some sort of an
organization that we're referring to yes
this is very yeah this is very nebulous
it gives it yeah specific would be
better
absolutely any other questions for the
representative thank you representative
thank you Mr chairman I always love
coming to this committee good people
here
thanks again and in great uh committee
fashion we'll all have great advice for
you you'll somebody will bring in an
amendment and we'll all stand up and
cheer that would be marvelous thank you
so much again chair recognizes Matthew
Bedford thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee representative Schmidt
thank you for bringing this bill
forward uh as mentioned I do live in
Bedford I'm glad to see one of my
Representatives here today as well as
own a small business in Rochester and I
am here to support this bill I do live
with crohn's disease and an osty device
so I am very familiar with the incidents
that can happen um to Simply put it
we're talking about people soiling
themselves and let's say it's tough to
talk about I'm nervous here talking
about it because implicitly I'm
admitting that I did it as well the
problem is is that there's a nonzero
number of businesses that prohibit
people from using the bathroom in these
moments of need and when I say a moment
of need you're talking four 5 seconds
from the moment that the urge hits to
accidents
happen as a patient and an individual
that lives with this I know that for
many this is talking about or this is
forcing us to make a decision to leave
the house during the day to go to work
to shop to be a member of society
removing some of that uncertainty is a
huge load off of our shoulders and
allows us to be part of life outside of
the
home it's uh I think it was pointed out
that there's 18 states that already have
a version of what's called Alley's law
in place uh I hope New Hampshire is the
19th um and again I just ask for
consideration of this bill it really is
low impact to the businesses and I
understand the concerns around abuse and
I hope the committee can find the right
amendments to uh make this work and pass
it quickly thank you very much thank you
would you take a question if we have any
oh yes absolutely let's have
one
no all right yes thank you thank you for
taking my question and I'll make it very
brief have you seen any of these cards
do you have a suggestion on who would
issue the card uh would it be a your
provider uh and could we have a
universal one that everybody would just
download the form I know that the
Crohn's cus Foundation of America the
ccfa they they have a example card on
their website um they they promote it as
a you know maybe your state doesn't have
the law but use this card and as was
pointed out by the representative is
that there's very few places that say no
um I had and then there is the uoaa card
as well um those are both pretty widely
accepted versions of this um material
thank you thank you
thank oh you got it just under the wire
I I just want to representative n thank
you not really a question I just wanted
to say thank you for your testimony on a
difficult subject thank you that needs
to be a question is would you believe
I'm very thankful for your testimony
would you believe having been in urgent
need myself at times as a mother of four
that um thank you for bringing up a
delicate uh topic thank you you thank
you sir chair recognizes Randy Mahoney
from
nashwa
good afternoon thank you and thank you J
representative Schmidt I'm the person
who requested this B could you either
move closer to the mic or move the mic
closer to you sorry can you hear me
either one thank you okay I'm the person
who contacted jit to um to pass this
bill or to request this bill um so I
really appreciate her bringing it
Forward I would like to bring also a
disclaimer I am from Michigan I've
worked in retail esta lishments when
this bill was passed so I can answer any
questions about that after I'm done with
my Spiel um I'd like to direct your
guys's attention to this kit I have with
me it consists of a sealed tupp Weare
bin it's lined with grocery bags and
inside there are baby wipes and a change
of
clothes if you had told me two years ago
that 3 million Americans that are grown
adults carry this in their car I would
have thought it was the grossest thing
I've ever heard but unfortunately it's a
reality for us
um in February of 2021 I had my daughter
Beverly after a healthy and uneventful
pregnancy birth triggered some weird
symptoms that I had never experienced
before and after many tests and Labs I
had I was diagnosed with crohn's disease
in May it's been almost a year since my
diagnosis and I have still not found an
effective medication meaning that I have
been in a constant state of moderate to
severe flare since my daughter was born
my affects my daily life severely on
average I use the bathroom R 19 times
during the day and five times at night
every single instance and I mean every
instance of me needing to use the
restroom is sudden and Urgent giving me
an average of only 90 seconds to make it
to a bathroom and yes I have timed it if
that 90 seconds elapses and I not yet
made it to the restroom I lose control
of my body and end up having an accident
these episodes are typically referred to
by as Crohn's attacks they leave me
unable to feed my
daughter unable to read her a book
before bed unable to attend meetings at
work and most importantly for this
meeting unable to run any errands or go
anywhere in my community unless I know
that there will be a bathroom
available this is because every time I
or one of the other 3 million Americans
diagnosed with IBD experience a Crohn's
attack and don't have access to a
restroom we rely on this and risk being
arrested in charged with indecent
exposure when we
do in July of last year I was shopping
in a small boutique with my sister when
I experienced a Crohn's attack I quickly
tried to go into the restroom in a
corner between some scarves and some
ponchos but it was locked when I
explained the situation in my diagnosis
and asked the employee behind the cash
register for the key I was told it was
an employee only restroom desperate and
not looking to engage in a confrontation
I tried to rush out to my car but did
not make it to the door human humiliated
defeated and degraded I did research on
what other people with crohn's do to
solve this issue and that's when I
learned about Ali's law or the restroom
access
act it allows people with Crohns or
similar diseases to present a card or
doctor's note that would grant them
access to employee only arrest rooms and
that's why we're here
today I know that business owners would
look at this request and think of it as
not being a matter of disability access
or discrimination I've been told many
times that if the bathroom isn't
available to anyone then their belief is
that it's not discrimination to Den it
to someone with a
disability I don't know how to stress
enough or to put into words convincing
enough that restroom access for
individuals with disabilities like mine
is simply and unequivocally a matter of
Equitable
access I reached out to family and
friends to try and come up with a good
enough analogy and the best one offered
was from my friend
Courtney Courtney suffers from a seizure
disorder for which she has a service dog
named Sky her seizures are sudden and
Urgent just as my Cron's attacks are
sudden and urgent she is unable to walk
to a store next door drive down the road
or go elsewhere to have her seizures
just as I am unable to make it elsewhere
during a Crohn's
attack Courtney is physically capable of
walking into a store on her own to
browse her shop and may not have a
seizure but the mere potential that she
might have one means that she is legally
entitled to have sky with her if
Courtney were to approach a store and be
denied access with her service dog that
store it effectively and legally become
inaccessible to her simply because of
the potential for a medical event and
the fact that she requires her dog to
support her through that medical event
similarly while I might be physically
capable of walking into a store and
shopping without incident the mere
potential that a Crohn's attack could
occur and that would I not that I would
not have time or the physical ability to
go elsewhere means that if a bathroom is
not available to me that business is
effectively also not available to me as
a direct result of my
disability the Americans with
Disabilities Act requires and urges
businesses to make reasonable
accommodations where possible for both
employees and customers with
disabilities so long as they do not
result in an undue burden being that
this bill does not require businesses to
open their restrooms to all customers
and that it makes exceptions for
instances where there might be a health
or safety risk I do not see how the
passing of this bill or the use of
bathrooms by select customers with
certain disabilities in supporting
documentation could be considered an
undue burden in fact I would argue that
not granting restroom access will result
in an undue burden for employees who
will end up having to mop up access when
I or people like me are refused access
to the restrooms and don't make it to
our
cars this bill is a matter of Equitable
access for those of us with bow related
disabilities businesses that do not have
restrooms available are just simply not
available to us passage of this bill
would allow people like me to
participate in our community and support
small businesses without fear of
embarrassment I urge the committee to
empathize and put yourselves in our
shoes no 28-year-old woman wants to
admit to a cashier that we don't have
control of our B ows no grown adult
wants to beg for a bathroom or admit
that we're about to have an accident and
absolutely nobody wants to use one of
these in a parking
lot but this is the reality of our
disability we do not have time to go
next door and we do not have the
physical ability to hold it we just
don't I sincerely hope that you're able
to see the need for this bill we suffer
so much in our daily lives the comfort
of knowing we will be able to access the
restroom is such a small and simple act
that requires almost nothing of business
owners and allows people like me the
ability to to leave productive
fulfilling and enriched lives and
interact with the community without fear
of humiliation or degradation without
bills like the restroom access act we
are left with this as our option it's
degrading it's disgusting it's
dehumanizing and it's
unnecessary thank you thank you so much
for telling us your story representative
kerk yes thank you for taking my
question I'm curious given particularly
what you just finished saying about the
degrading aspect we've talked talked a
little bit about various conditions um
and I'm wondering how you feel about
would a whatever identification we have
from the provider that says you should
be allowed should it have a diagnosis or
do you think that should be confidential
and perhaps it should just use the
language which is on page 18 of the um
information that representative schmidth
sent which they used the word restroom
duress which covered a number of
different issues why somebody might wish
to do you think would you find it
less offensive if you just had a card
said I should be granted immediate
access rather than saying I have Crohn's
disease yes personally I would find that
less offensive but I've also in my
experience since having this disease
learned that people don't really listen
until you say Crohn's so and I guess it
would depend on um the person's
comfortability with talking about their
diagnosis but I do think that the option
Weber
you may not be the right person to ask
this but you were the one requesting the
bill so I'm going to ask you anyway if
it's inappropriate just let me know um
is is this Michigan's law specifically
and if you know are there have the
states that passed the law passed
exactly the same language or are there
modifications in the various States no I
believe there are modifications um for
example I know that Massachusetts has
this law and I work in Mass it so I have
looked up what their law is and they
have more of a fine system where it's
like the first um offense they find a
certain amount and then the second
offense they find more um so I know how
that's different in Massachusetts I
don't necessarily know how it's
different in Michigan other than that my
uh my manager had Crohn's disease so she
was familiar with the law so when she's
the one who trained in place that we
were required to um to give access for
these
you I think that that would be very
helpful it's my experience in Mich being
in Michigan when I go home that many
business owners don't even know this law
exists and you almost end up having to
argue with them which kind of wastes the
time when you're trying to rush to the
bathroom so I think that that would be
helpful in making business owners aware
that this is a lawn that they could be
fined because I certainly don't want
anyone to be fined for not knowing but I
still want everyone with in New
Hampshire with crohn's or any other
disability like this to have access so
um I think that something that would
make business owners aware and their um
staff aware would be really helpful in
the sense that it would prevent more
people from having to have accidents
explain thank you for your testimony did
she have questions about the card I'm
sorry did I see a hand no I didn't see a
hand oh sorry okay you can have an a
fellowship after okay yeah that' be good
no I would would like to ask oh you
would question um is there any kind of U
sign like you said to put the sign would
you like to put that in there to
encourage I don't know how to write it
either but uh some kind of sign not so
that people would would become
recognized you know that's the bathroom
law and uh that uh it's okay to let
people do it and then you could have the
conditions as part of the education yes
helpful
thank you thank you and that concludes
the last pink card we had and I would
just say before closing the hearing this
is according to what I've been told an
early bill so representative Schmidt if
there's an amendment coming with a bunch
of stuff we need to have it fairly
soon with that
I ask just a quick question of what
committee it might be going to after
ours sorry if it's an early Bill do you
know what committee it goes to after
ours I do not
okay close the hearing on House Bill
FN next up House Bill
1507 requiring child child care
investigatory findings to be published
timely and the chair calls
representative MC Williams who's right
here
thank you very much chair peon um it's a
pleasure to be in front of you
colleagues um and I'm looking forward to
presenting this bill uh I'm just going
to give you a little bit of background
on uh child care and the ongoing
saga uh first of all there was a
uh there was a study committee in
2019 uh to look into issues with child
care businesses and how we can better
smooth the rails for child care
businesses to succeed in New Hampshire
um so I got the bill passed in Spring
2019 and then I chaired the committee to
study issues and impediments to starting
running and growing Home and Commercial
daycare facilities in New Hampshire so
full disclosure I am a mom of three I
have four-year-old twins who are
currently in a daycare and I have a
one-year-old that I'm not quite ready to
send to daycare but I will be soon uh so
I am personally invested in making sure
that we have adequate daycare for
facilities in New Hampshire and also
trying to find ways to get rid of
impediments that seem to be making it
harder to run that kind of a business in
New Hampshire um so I've emailed the
entire committee um the findings from
that study committee that happened in
2019 um just sort of on background and
so some of the things that we heard from
different uh operators of facilities um
included uh feeling as though there was
not a a sense of fairness when you are
operating a facility and the state comes
in to do a surprise inspection which
they do once a year and you get quote
unquote written up um and then you have
to deal with that do what it is what is
required there are many different ways
that you can uh respond to being written
up uh but let's just say that there was
something bad and it's not bad enough to
close your facility but it's a black
mark on your record and so that is
published on the State website um and so
for some facilities who had been in
business for say 20 years having a black
mark on your record from 19 years ago
still shows up on the State website um
and that could be construed against you
as the person who was responsible for
that is probably long gone the child or
if there was a child involved in that
incident is now in high school uh and so
you know things change but having a
permanent published record that the
public can see can actually move against
and be used against a business that has
successfully operated for 20 years and
so also just as a side note we do have
um Child Care Facilities that are often
uh rebranded or started over with the
same people under a different name and
so it seemed like that was kind of
unfair to to allow a facility that
gotten written up or even was forced to
close and then rebranded and has this
Sterling reputation of the last year but
the reality is they had a bit of a
history um so that all of this is just
to summarize uh testimony that we heard
from different Child Care Facility
operators uh so in response to that um
i' I've put language in this bill very
specifically to say that um the intent
is that
the let me find the exact language here
end of paragraph Roman numeral 2 line
n uh it shall be available on the
website for a period of three years and
so that kind of gets rid of this tail
concern that bad information could be up
there from 15 20 years ago that could
reflect poorly on a facility when that's
long long ago been addressed um in
addition there were also some concerns
by Child Care Facility operators that
when you do get written up um there
really didn't seem to be a fair way for
that to be delivered to the daycare
operator you didn't get an email uh you
may not even get a formal US mail
envelope or if you did receive that
which was not always the case you
received that after your write up had
already been published on the State
website so there was really really no
opportunity to respond to the write up
or perhaps say this may be a
misunderstanding I'd like to appeal your
findings um so it just seemed like it
was very much heavy-handed and one
directional and so the intention of um
let's see let me go down here section
three of the bill is really that the
department provide notice by email or if
they don't have an email address US mail
and that needs to go out um so that
there's an opportunity to respond to
that and that the response can then be
published as well on the State website
depending on what the infraction was
obviously some infractions there may not
be a response but but some there may and
so that's at least giving an opportunity
for a rebuttal when the public is
looking at and comparing different
daycare facilities they can say okay
well it looks like this one has four
infractions but they responded to them
and it looks like things were addressed
this one has four infractions they have
provided no response oo I don't know how
I feel about that so really what we're
trying to do is even the playing field
and also be equal to every single child
care facility that gets a write up
giving them an opportunity for a
response if they choose to take it and
also making sure that they receive the
findings before it's published to the
public without feeling as though they
have a recourse and so I'm hoping that
I've summarized sort of the history and
what we've heard in prior testimony I'm
sure there are probably some folks
behind me who'd like to testify about
this but I'm just carrying the water to
hope that we can push this through um it
was very much a bipartisan effort to do
the study committee and I'm hoping that
we can have a bipartisan effort to get a
yes vote out of committee for this and I
thank you for your time happy to answer
questions representative
Shapiro yes thank you Mr chair and thank
you for bringing this bill and trying to
increase the amount of daycare available
um is there an appeal process when
someone is um alleged to have an
infraction um there is but we're
currently working to address that
because the appeal process um
in a nutshell the way the appeal process
works right now is you have someone from
the the department comes and does a
surprise inspection at your facility and
then you say oh well that write up was
wrong because you you end up appealing
to the person who did the write up and
their supervisor so it kind of feels
like the deck is stacked against you to
do the appeal and then there is no
higher authority right now to try to
overturn what tends to be a rubber stamp
decision by the person who did the write
up in their boss so we're looking at
other Industries um specifically real
estate uh to figure out if there's a way
that we can do something more fair for
the appeals process but that's not
specifically addressed in this Bill
thank you thank you representative Woods
uh thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um it uh refers in
line n elsewhere about available on the
website for a period of three years does
that mean that it is expunged after that
time so the intention is that the record
always exists at the department but not
necessarily on the website okay so in
other words if I were investigating say
I've got a child and I want to S it and
I I've heard some things but the website
looks pretty clean I still have access
to this and it's a permanent record it
is a permanent record at the department
but not necessarily on the Department's
website is that stated followup Mr chair
yes uh is is that stated clearly on the
website
that uh this is just the last three
years there may be other information so
the people don't get the impression that
if this is clear well I'm well there's
nothing there it sounds like you're
proposing a bill Amendment well I'm just
know I'm just inquiring in the mechanism
the website right now doesn't say
anything about that because the website
has that 20 years or more of History so
in order to change it there might be a
little asterisk to say records are
provided for the past three years for
additional information contact the
department Department yeah okay so that
would need to happen happy to talk about
our Amendment somebody in the audience
is Raising her hand with authority so I
you of and certific the department of
health services and I'll come
sorry for the record my name is dorine
shakley I'm the manager of the
Department of Health and Human Services
licensing and certification which
includes childcare licensing and to your
question our website currently says um
that if you would like information for
visits that occurred more than three
years ago please contact our office and
we do not post everything there is only
F three to five years on our current
website without this legislation Thank
you very much representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman and also
thank you representative for taking my
question can you or
someone help me understand are
inspections done routinely randomized or
by complaint and could Mr chairman kind
have a follow question for that
answer my understanding based on
testimony that I received is that they
are random annual inspections there is
no prior notice but they happen once a
year so any day could be an inspection
day at a daycare facility Mr chair if I
can follow up thank you now if they have
a follow-up inspection and during that
inspection it's determined that the
facility addressed the infraction that
was cited before do they have to wait a
full three years why could that not be
taken down off the website that is not a
question for me unfortunately I don't
have a response to that question
representative kerk thank you
um yes I actually have two prong
question here one is you commented about
the difficulty of conceivably somebody
going out of business rebranding and
reopening should there be a cross
reference to the either the owner or the
operator of the facility such that if
they just change a name that information
could still be found under that person's
name and well actually I do have a short
question after that but thoughts on that
in the interest of safety I think that
makes a lot of sense to follow an
individual especially if it's the owner
identified owner of the facility I'm
just not sure about the implementation
of
that and the follow follow the followup
is considering how slow the ponies are
getting up to the North Country uh do
you think that the 15 days if somebody
does not have email which would probably
be unusual but if they don't do you
think the 15 days is a sufficient
turnaround time for um snail
mail so the the requirement is that it
needs to be published on the 30th day so
15 days for notice should give you two
weeks in between even if it was 18 days
or something uh but I would be open to
extending those two time periods if it
was really considered unrealistic for
mail to get there within the 30-day and
you any other questions for the
representative
thank you very much thank you very much
we have already heard from darene shley
from DHHS and in this handy
little list of names and jobs and
contact information we were given lo and
behold there she is licensing and
certification manager Child Care Health
Facilities she has filled out a pink
down
hello okay hello hi again um thank you
chairman pearon and committee members
again my name for the record is dorine
shley I am the manager of the Bureau of
Licensing and certification at the
Department of Health and Human Services
many of you I recognize from when we
were in person the session before last
and many of you from last session when
we were on Zoom um um I am I oversee all
um licensed facilities from birth to end
of life so I oversee child care
licensing um our CMS certified hospitals
nursing homes um ambulatory search
centers all of our adult licensed
assisted living facilities etc etc um so
I am here today to let everyone know
that as our representative has um
sponsor of this bill has said we have
worked very hard over the past several
years on this bill and many other bills
um and we are um certainly in support of
this the one thing I would bring um the
committee's attention to is line eight
it says 21 days we would only ask that
to be consistent with line number 10 we
add the word business between 21 and
days I'm certainly um available to
answer questions if you have any some of
the questions that were asked prior um I
might be able to address if you still
Weber thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question uh we began to
get a little bit into the area of what
happens when somebody has addressed an
issue um and I'm so sorry this didn't go
to the children and family law committee
where the members probably already knew
all the answers to these questions but
uh when somebody has a violation and
they get notified of a
violation and it's something like
something that has to be fixed or a
position or something that has to be
changed on the website does it merely
note the violation or does it also note
when the violation has been cleared up
so um thank you for your question I'm so
I guess an overview of the process would
be very helpful to certain thank you um
and I do think that's important to this
discussion and to this bill so um what
happens is we go out and um it was
mentioned numerous times I think that
our visits are unexpected unannounced
and that is pursuant to law um and that
is across the board from birth to end of
life we are required to unexpectedly do
at least one annual visit so that people
um aren't ready for us except they're
ready for us every day and um we also do
complaint inspections investigations um
when we receive complaints from the
community um and what happens is through
our investigatory process which can
include on-site visits um telephone
calls interviews documentation we um end
with a report a statement of findings
that is then delivered to the leny who
is given 21 days to respond with a
corrective action plan which is also
posted online with the statement of
findings that corrective action plan
specifies by the lensey by the program
what their um what their feedback is
what the deficiency was how they're
going to fix it when they fixed it um
and any other additional comments they
might have should they um dispute a
finding that we um that we found they
have that right as well the only thing
we ask is that people be respectful that
it's a public website and ask them not
to use inflammatory comments or um
language that is not acceptable um but
other than that that also gets posted so
I think that answers your question
representative thank
Merchant thank you Mr chair and also
thank you for taking my question um I
asked this before to representative MC
Williams and the question was if the
infraction has been resolved between
inspections does it have to in your
opinion remain On The Board website for
the full three years or can it be taken
down once the infraction has been
resolved to the Department's
satisfaction so um in my opinion it
would require um RSA it would require
change to the the law um legislation
requires us um in all in the adult world
and in the child care world to leave all
statements of findings posted publicly
for a period of I think in some areas
it's five years it's three to five years
um however um you would be able to see
as um a a consumer you would be able to
see in
2017 this citation occurred but in 2018
19 and 20 it no longer occurred so you
would know that it was fixed um or um
but I I mean I currently we are required
to do
that Mr chairman H up so what I'm
hearing I want to be clear about this it
does require a change in the RSA and
would the department be supportive of
such a change in the RSA would you work
with us in trying to figure out how to
come up with some common
ground I would certainly be supportive
of working with you on that um along
with our attorneys yes absolutely
representative
Shapiro yes thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking this question I may have
misunderstood but it sounds like I heard
that this bill specifies three years of
a violation being on the website I also
heard testimony that um sometimes
violations remain for 17 years or 20
years and then I heard you say that at
most they're on the website for 3 to
five years unless I'm mixing things up
no I I think I heard the same and I'm
not sure I I couldn't speak to the
Beyond five years um as um since I've
been with the Department the law has
required us to have for five years we
have with this legislation that has been
ongoing for two years I think um we
updated our website already to show that
if you needed and that was an answer to
representative Wood's question that if
in fact you wanted 20 years could you
get that yes you give us a call and we
would get that for you because it is
permanently on record right now if you
were go to the childcare licensing it is
five years of History um because that I
believe is what the legislation says now
but we are certainly open and willing to
change to three years which we've
already noted on our website
followup okay so you're so from what I'm
gathering um it's currently things are
on there for 5 years and you're if the
Law changes you're willing to make it
three years absolutely but um I would
ask of you as the expert um is there an
advantage to it being three years or is
or would something be lost if it wasn't
five
years
so I appreciate that question and I
think as in my role now I don't see the
difference between three years or five
years if I were a
parent I might think differently and
want 10 to 15 years but then I'd call me
and say Hey can I have the last 10 years
um so it would depend on what my role
was for the
information does that help or do I still
need to clarify
that you may continue representative I
understand that um a cautious parent
might want more information and a
daycare who's fixed the problem and
doesn't want bad PR to have a shorter
time but I guess I'm asking you for your
opinion as someone who certainly has
more expertise than myself maybe more
expertise than anyone in in the room um
whether three years is a reasonable
amount of time I think it
is thank representative kerk yes just a
quick question I'd asked this earlier
but but since you know more about this
obviously uh would there be a way for
the Department to cross reference uh
info regarding either owners or
operators such that a bad actor couldn't
just uh Rebrand or change the name of
the facility and still be just as bad a
person is there a way to cross reference
that so um I wrote your question down
your comment down because I think it's
very important and we see that in child
care as well as in adult care we've seen
that a lot in our nursing home
facilities lately um and a lot of name
changes so I noted that and I'm going to
go back to the office and we're going to
start that discussion because that
doesn't happen in our current
environment but I think it's a really
great idea so thank you for bringing it
up
again would you be able to get back to
us rapidly because we have to have an
amendment we would want to be able to I
mean no could it be done before we would
put it in an amendment Define
rapidly like by the end of this this is
not an early bill so it is not so
sometime in the next four weeks would be
wonderful absolutely thank you any
further questions for manager shley well
this side of the aisle okay
representative Acton thank
you thank you Mr chair and um for the
record I was on the study committee that
was mentioned by the sponsor and um so
commissioner uh director shley I I
recollect that when we did the study
committee the um complaints stayed on
the website at that point for a a very
long time and is one of the reasons why
we did the the study committee so are
you testifying that the length of time
changed since then since we did the
study
committee so I I'm going to you you
mentioned complaints so maybe complaints
were handled differently than the annual
monitoring visits I'm going to follow up
on that question before the end of the
week um I know that currently there's
only 5 years or on at least the two that
I just looked at in the galley um let me
confirm that to make sure and I'm sorry
if I
misstated um actually follow up follow
up please yes okay
that I guess would you believe that at
the time the reason why we did the study
committee was because we had had so many
people from the industry complaining
about how long those things were on
there and that appears to have changed
since then so that's that's good but I
just wanted to get the the time frame of
that and um uh one final followup chair
one one more um are you aware that after
we did the study committee we received
uh at least two complaints from Facility
Owners who feel that they they got a
spot inspection within a several days of
testifying and they felt it was done in
retribution
I believe that was brought up in the
prior committee and I believe um that
there's legislation going forward on
that I I I do want to say because I did
hear you know a comment over here um
this has taken years of conversation and
I will agree with your comment there
were a lot of challenges opportunities
problems over the course of the last two
years and I am very happy to be able to
sit here in front of this committee and
let you know that there aren't a lot of
people out here behind me right from the
community feeling the same way they felt
two years ago and I think that says a
lot to the work that we've done together
we've done a lot so yes were there
issues you bet um and I I I don't know
how I mean am I aware of that yes I am
aware of that um do I believe that the
people that thought that happened firmly
believe that yes do we take that kind of
if we investigate that internally with
our HR and if anyone in our department
overall acts in any manner like that
it's unacceptable and we would take
yes thank you so much manager Shockley
for your testimony and I have no further
pink cards so I will bring the hearing
on House Bill
1507 to a
close and just uh to the sponsor yeah we
have about a month for you to bring in
your
question question of the chair about
procedure question please I am am
inferring from your uh statements to the
various people who have brought us bills
today that you are not planning on
appointing a lot of subcommittees to
work on these bills is that correct I'm
taking them as they come if it sounds
like the prime
sponsor
um knows that there's this or that that
could be added they are becoming an ad
hoc committee with people from us from
the committee here um I'd already spoken
with one representative about a bill
that's coming up where I suspect we will
have a subcommittee okay so it's not a
blanket policy you're just sort of
taking it on a Case by casee Bas yes I
am thank you for the question thank you
very much I appreciate the explanation
any
time open the hearing on House Bill 1390
rela relative to access to language
translation services and tele medicine
flown in at Great expense from right
over there is representative Murray hi
thank you for the record my name is uh
representative Murray I represent the
town of amher New Hampshire Hillsboro
District 22 thank you sorry about that
um this bill was brought to my attention
um through constituents seeking
essentially parity in what they
experience in inperson medical
appointments um and for brevity um to
explain sort of what I am am what the
intent of the piece of legislation is is
for example that when an individual who
is limited English proficient deaf heart
of hearing needs an interpreter or
translator at an in-person doctor's
appointment they may request one in one
is provided to them free of charge that
is in Statute in a federal law what we
are asking for is is that individuals
who are participating in teleah Health
Medicine have the same opportunity
afforded to them so with that I'll take
any
questions I have in my notes that the
tele medicine is not in Federal
Regulations now but but in person is
correct correct okay that is correct and
you said at no additional charge uh
that's in an additional charge to
somebody is it it's not to the patient
is it to the provider it uh that is
actually a question that I cannot answer
maybe there's somebody in Insurance
behind me or within DHHS who could um um
we'll bring that person up when you're
finished yeah thank you yeah no problem
um but to answer your question U Mr
chair um it is in statute that it is not
patient any
questions
we have a whole 40 minutes to think of
who's my goto always has a question
person representa no I I get to do that
that's because I have the big seat
representative
gay thank you thank you Mr chairman I
was just wondering how it works uh do
you uh do you use um an internet
connection to get a translator who can
speak whatever you need that is
something thing that I um often times
have seen even on current um platforms
for telea Health Medicine there are
close captioning transcription down
there for certain types of requests that
might be made I'm um but if they are
specific in language or nature there's
oftentimes um even in hospitals or
doctor's offices there are translators
who you can call that speak specific
languages who will come to the
appointment and facilitate that
conversation or perhaps um then ALS also
be present um
virtually followup
followup I I guess I'm shocked right now
thinking that you're supposed to that's
okay question are you supposed to are
you supposed to you believe I'm in shock
if well yeah do you mind um I guess I
can understand that you can offer any
language if you do it um through the
internet and I you know I like using
translators myself but if you've got a
patient
there the
idea are you gwi are you thinking that
people should get a real live person who
speaks Chinese or uh Tagalog or whatever
are you thinking they have to come
physically to a an appointment if you
know ahead or do just seems like like
tele medicine would not be hard to
provide the same service if you already
did it electronically uh if I'm
following your question I I think um so
that that request is already made at a
doctor's office or a hospital and I am
not mandating or dictating how they get
that translator there whether it is a
person who is participating
telephonically to translate between the
patient and the doctor or if that's some
other service that medical providers
have out there that is
already good to go um but what I am
saying is that that request should be
met for individuals who have that need
and are participating in teleah health
medicine before we continue if there's
anyone who is going to answer any of
these
questions who comes from a department or
an agency I'd like to have a pink card
I'd like to have the you don't get to
keep the pink card I get the pink card
thank you if there's any written
testimony please bring it up as
well good representative
Merchant if if I know that most healthc
care facilities use telephonic
translation so basically at that point
in time gay my understanding is that
they'll call a service and the service
will have different people who speak
different
languages connected by a phone so the
patient is on one side provider on that
side along with the translator on the
other side to translate the conversation
between the patient and the provider but
telephonically representative
Weber I think mine's been asked and
answered Mr chairman thank
you representative Woods uh thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question um are are you aware of the uh
tele Health commission that's currently
in place I am aware of that okay and uh
are do you know if they're addressing
this uh the reason I asked uh uh would
you be aware that the teleah health uh
codes have been completely revamped they
might be able to uh I think uh might
have addressed
that uh to answer your question I do
know about the teleah Health commission
I
I am not aware that that sponsor or
co-sponsor was on the commission but
there are others that are on the bill
who are and so um we still think that
this is something that should be in
statute um well thank and I'm speaking
for myself no other member sorry
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
for taking the question um I'm I'm
curious about the technical aspects of
including an interpreter in a telea
health visit are we talking about
somehow getting them into a one-on-one
video chat that might be set up up is
only a one on sorry setup is only a
one-on-one thing for privacy issues are
we talking about a party call how is
this technically going to be
accomplished or is this something where
we're going to say here's what you have
to do provider you have to solve this
issue
what so let me be very careful here
because again I am not a provider I was
brought this issue to a family who did
not English was not their first language
and they were trying to facilitate
an medical appointment and had um a
younger relative trying to translate
very complicated medical things between
themselves and one another and I feel
like that is not an
appropriate
um opportunity and there's a huge leeway
and opportunity for there to be a
miscommunication when it's not somebody
well versed in the medical community
medical knowledge and these telephonic
transcribers have that knowledge to be
able able to translate accurately back
chairman this this is a question that's
bothered me for a while uh with with
tele medicine or any other source
dealing with Deen heart of
hearing psychotherapy which is what I
used to
do is based on a relationship and the
development of a
relationship one of the things that
happened with a young fellow I was
seeing was that the relationship was
developing with The
Interpreter and not me and therefore the
question of outcomes of service provided
to information to the
commissioner perhaps should deal with
that issue because it made it extremely
difficult and U I had to stop The
Interpreter and try to do it by using
notes back and forth and it really
didn't work particularly well uh at all
but that whole issue about Psychotherapy
and the importance of the
relationship uh is is is extremely
important when we're dealing with def
heart of
hearing and I'd be interested to hearing
subject is there a specific question
[Music]
around the intent of the legislation
with a
translator is that what you're asking
I'm I'm sorry well what what happens I
think at least what happened with me was
the relationship that should be
developing with the therapist develop
with The Interpreter and the person is
looking at that interpreter and the
relationship is developing and I as the
therapist who's trained to deal with
this belong off to the
side so that the therapy from my point
of
view did not work particularly
well and uh some others maybe Joe or
some others have had this
experience but it's been something that
has concerned me for quite a while and
now that I'm along with the chairman on
the def Hut of hearing commission it's
come
back that's something to consider I do
know that most transcribers and
translators with respect to the depth in
the heart of hearing are extremely
professional in their work and work
diligently to communicate the needs of
the patient with their whomever they're
translating for whatever reason re
Shapiro thank you Mr chair I I don't
really have a question but I think I
have an answer to an earlier question do
I
if do you believe that I used to work as
an administrator in a um Community
Mental Health Center and it was our
responsibility to provide translation
services and our responsibility to pay
for them thank you I would believe
[Laughter]
you darene shley if you would come up
please you are not darene shley I know
Daren shley you are not darene shley
you representative Pearson and committee
members um uh chairman Pearson and
committee members my name is John
Williams I'm director of legislative
affairs and we actually hadn't come here
today to be um ready to testify in this
bill because as a concept we're
supportive of the bill that you see
before you certainly it it genders the
thought of open communication uh with a
patient and trying to uh U to get over
any language barriers that could be
whether in person or intell health the
only reason it has connection with the
department and very similar to that
earlier piece of legislation today that
you heard that there was overlap between
the Department of Education and our
agency is that it was um the um drafters
of this bill at the office of
legislative Services working with um
represent Murray decided that um and I'm
just speculating this based upon
placement because our agency this is not
our requested Bill nor were we uh
requested to be participating in the
drafting of it but I'm speculating
because there's just so much work to do
for all of us that the concept here was
to embed it in our health facility
statute Under The Lure statute so there
would be teeth to this bill for purposes
of enforcing the provisions of the
language of the bill so that's why we
sit before you today and uh from our
perspective where this is in line with
um open access to Services through tele
Health tele medicine and to looking to
you also represent Pearson in your
multiple roles uh as being the chair of
the committee that actually looks at the
issues of the deaf and heart of hearing
uh I actually be fascinated to find out
whether or not your committee was a
proponent behind this bill and would be
supportive of the provisions of the
legislation absent the policy committee
before you so because the answer to that
question is no but I'd still like to
take
credit yeah there there's a famous
statement by uh President Kennedy on
that so with that um I'm uh looking to
miss Shockley because she did such a
great job at the last hearing and the
questions that were posed go well beyond
Health Facilities Administration which
she is very skilled and Adept and I
would turn over any questions to her but
because you're touching upon various
areas even outside of the department as
it relates to the office of profession
Li Insurance certification because
providers who are involved with telea
health they are the regulatory entities
that look at those issues who can
participate uh and all those things so
it goes well beyond the scope of Miss
Shockley in the department but we do
want to say uh in reviewing the bill and
ref Murray that the department is fine
with the provisions in here uh we do
anticipate that there could be some
level obviously of an impact to the
provider Community but as a whole I
think everybody in the spirit of working
together want to make sure that there is
less um barriers to access access to
Services particularly around tele Health
tele medicine and with that I will
conclude my remark that we're available
for any questions but I'd like to ask
Miss shle if she had anything to add no
Weber forgive me if I'm just putting
something in that wasn't in there when
you started your remarks you
made a statement about the issue for the
Department is the drafter placement of
the bill were you going to suggest that
it should be in a different part of the
statutes because at that point I didn't
keep up quickly enough with my notes so
I I was just trying to clarify if if you
were asking for it to be moved somewhere
else in the statute or whether it's but
then your next remarks made me think it
was okay where it was so i' I'd like a
little more information on that if if
you would considering you have already
heard I think about seven going on eight
bills today we're going to be working on
amendments I'm I'm not here trying to
create more work for you however um
because those of us whove worked in
telea health tele medicine actually
drafted the language and worked on it
for years repr McKay uh advancing this
from its early infancy from 2008 2009
that you have to look at telea Health
tele medicine at least from our
perspective under the insurance statutes
as well as under our Medicaid statutes
in terms of the pay for for those
services so that's very far a field from
where you are with this legislation
which is trying to come up with a way to
mandate enforcement of some level with
in having providers who do provide these
services to uh do meaningful language
access to uh limited English uh
proficient speakers I'm leading reading
directly from the bill itself um again
we're here specifically because of our
thought that this came to the licensing
piece but it it is also equally likely
with a little more thought and taking a
little more time there could be other
placements you would want to look at
either under the office of professional
lure and certification statutes dealing
with the various providers who provide
tele Health tele medicine and there's a
whole array of statutes that that would
touch upon also under the Department of
Insurance there Provisions regarding um
the um tele Health tele I'm looking at
represent Shapiro because I had some
memory of us working on something
dealing with tele Health tele medicine
last four or five years and also looking
to the department under
167 um RSA 167 which is our provision
around Medicaid for T Health tele
medicine and it's why Miss Shockley
brought me up as her de facto kind of
attorney for the day since her other
attorney is in ways and means right
Weber I guess my question is can we
simplify all of this by just saying all
this is
doing is extending something that is
already being done with procedures that
are already being in place to another
delivery system and therefore we don't
have to reinvent the wheel in every
single part of the
statute is that a fair way of thinking
of it I mean we could just leave it as
it is because we're already deliver ing
this service and it's being paid for by
somebody and we don't necessarily need
to know who it's just if we're treating
a
patient uh via in person or telea
medicine we're going to have to provide
accommodations again we will just state
that we are fine with the current
language here but I do need to make the
articulation that these are licensed
facilities not providers under this
section that's why I'm saying with a
little more time and energy you may want
to identify other statutory placement
for purposes of ensuring that this will
go across to include providers that's
why I reference the office of
professional Li Insurance certification
statutes because that's the provider
level responsibility around T Health
tele medicine not not under our
licensing facilities and miss miss shley
you
agree
yes I agree but I think John's comments
like right there helped clarify that
that the RSA 151 what we oversee and
regulate our health facilities and this
addition looks specific to the providers
in the facilities so if the goal is for
um regulatory oversight that may not
fall under our purview though we are in
language representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and also
thank you for taking my question you
touched upon the issue of insurance
which sort of what I'm thinking thr and
help me here is that there's
a process of building the insurance
company for this cost if we have a
telephonic translator and so forth today
does a facility or a provider anyone
using it build the insurance company in
the insurance companies required to pay
for it or is it something in which the
facility is taken as part of the overall
reimbursement the cost is included in
that re overall
reimbursement and you've now exceeded my
my knowledge base I would have to defer
to someone else to answer that question
thank
you representative
fome thank you chairman Pearson thanks
for uh letting me ask this question
um this is just curiosity because I
don't know as much about these
laws if someone comes to your office to
the provider facility and they speak
Chinese um you don't have interpreters
for Chinese you have Spanish you have
Russian you have
whatever can you refer them to a
different Facility Who then may have a
Chinese person without getting in
trouble with this law like is every
language and I would have to defer to
the provider Community as to what is the
current state of matters how they
address it I mean my knowledge is that
most provider communities provide some
level to the extent that they have the
resources to do that whether as you know
is simply from your phones nowadays you
can go and convert language from one to
the next it so so I would have to defer
to somebody else about what currently is
out there what we would require in terms
of a licensing perspective here under
dorin shop is just to make sure that
there's compliance with the federal
citations here for the cfrs relative to
those facilities offering whatever is
required under federal law for those
kind of
services so doesn't it come down to
whatever the law says we have to do
about languages in an in-person
visit now you've got to do it in a tele
medicine
visit
lawyer
representative
Mayon um thank you chairman Pearson and
uh thank you for taking this question um
one of my questions is how this actually
gets implemented in a tella Health visit
I know that there's lots of different
ways to have tella Health you could have
screen to screen you could have it on as
a telephone is that set up in the ones
that providers and Facilities have
already invested in is it compatible
with introducing language services or
are we asking them to potentially
purchase a whole new
platform and and chairman Pearson
respectfully um that is beyond our
knowledge base here as to what the
provider community does I can give you a
very high level explanation but I think
the level of detail you're looking for
represent Lon really is best served by
uh representative either through the
office of professional LIC Insurance
certification they're great to work with
um attorney uh Lindsay Courtney is their
executive director and I'm happy to have
her be in touch with anybody on this
committee as it may relate to getting
the right person from oplc in touch with
you about expectations for for providers
we we try to be very clear we're we're a
big agency but when I'm getting out when
we're getting outside of our our pond
Dorian you will let me
know I'm speaking for myself but I'm
sensing maybe more than myself that
there there is sympathy very much for
this but I I need to know some more
detail as to
how so we' be looking forward to that
before we work on this again
representative waving off okay anybody
representative
Weber
you may not be the right person for me
to ask this question but I'm going to
ask it anyway you're right here would
[Music]
I be safe in
assuming that all of those people to
whom this is
addressed many of whom have lobbyists to
monitor legislation on their behalf and
none of whom seem to be here unless
they're pink cards that we haven't seen
or or
otherwise uh who are the absence of
anybody here to explain to us why this
is going to be terribly inconvenient for
any of the providers it
question is that question for the
Department um so um I think you're
you're identifying the two people before
you today are here to talk to you about
the bill in the four corners in front of
you as it relates to facilities
licensing we are not the office of
professional licensure and certification
we are happy to get people connected
with them the lobbying of the government
relations Community they're wonderful to
work with and strong proponents of the
importance of teleah Health tele
medicine and but I'm not in a position
to asking any of them to please approach
you to start answering some of the very
good questions good questions that this
committee is is offering um we do think
that the the underlying bill here we are
fine fine with this and if this is all
you did you would not hear anything from
the Department of Health and Human
Services other than we were fine
with any further
you this concludes the hearing on House
Bill 1390 and we have about a
13-minute
break
for
having
about
you
without
remember
I
the
know
it
okay
than
not
whatever
she
worried
I think we're going to EXA we ought to
do
a
oh um E Yeah e
early
situation
I
remember
hav
just want everybody to know that since
we're going to be on television you have
to sign a release and that's important
because then you get residuals every
reruns
SP
yeah
yes open the hearing on House Bill
1634 fnaa relative to state grants for
researching the effects on the human
body of covid-19 vaccines chair
recognizes representative grion the
primary
sponsor thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee committee um my
name is Jeff grion I'm the
representative for Grafton County
District 16 specifically from the town
of Wentworth as much as is known about
covid-19 much more remains unknown and
we've heard terms like Spike proteins
and cyto storms but since most of us are
not microbiologists or virologists our
understanding is very limited and we are
dependent on the Integrity of
researchers to inform us of their
findings fully and TR truthfully I won't
go into an explanation unless you want
it of exactly what is happening in the
body with the viruses I have looked it
up from those who have explained it but
the pandemic precipitated the rapid
production of vaccines aimed at
stimulating the production of antibodies
that would prevent the spike protein
from binding to target cells and if you
see those pictures on the news of this
orb with the things protruding from it
like rays of the sun those things that
are protruding from it are the spike
proteins and it's those Spike proteins
that will adhere to the cells of your
body my body anybody once the virus
enters the body and it will attempt to
um attach itself to a healthy body
cell which will then later cause damage
and the infection and uh and and go on
to to produce problems for you but the
vaccines that have been introduced our i
l to make us immune to the virus they
use newly developed mRNA technology
that's designed to produce the same
Spike protein as the virus itself but in
a more controlled manner so as to teach
the body to develop a proper immune
response yielding to immunity from the
actual virus that's all well and good
it's what it should be but these mRNA
vaccines are not the same as traditional
vaccines such as polio MMR small poox
they don't use the actual virus to
develop
the vaccine that means the MRNA vaccines
produce the same Spike proteins as the
virus but that's by Design these Spike
proteins should stay firmly attached to
the outside of the muscle cells at the
injection site so that the immune system
recognizes them and makes the specific
immune response however a study
conducted at Bristol Medical School in
the UK showed that some spike proteins
become soluble and float in the
bloodstream where they can wind up in
VAR organs of the body and one common
place that Spike proteins have been
found is the capillaries of the heart
resulting in inflammation and clot
formation in a study uh published by the
National Institutes for health entitled
be be aware of SARS Cove 2 Spike protein
there's more that meets the eye the
authors warn quote certain antibodies in
the blood of infected patients appear to
change the shape of the spike protein so
as to make it more likely to bind to
cells and it goes on further to say
quote the spike protein by itself
without being part of the Corona virus
can damage endothelial cells and disrupt
the blood brain barrier so this means
that the spike protein produced by the
vaccine may damage endothelial cells and
disrupt the bloodb brain barrier another
study published by the national institut
for health in December of last year
States the SARS Cove 2 Spike protein
disrupts human cardiac parasite function
so in other words these Spike proteins
adversely affect the heart so we know
from from hearing in the news stories uh
we know that people have experienced
blood clots subsequent to receiving a
vaccine we know many young people have
experienced myocarditis or pericarditis
following vaccination an alarming number
of athletes of all skill levels have
collapsed on their fields of play and
have died all of whom were vaccinated
shortly before the episode and I have a
list of over 75 names of athletes from
around the world who have suddenly died
of heart failure shortly after receiving
the vaccine now this is not a Slam
against vaccines it's just this is new
technology and the and the bill before
you is is intended to study scientific
study of the effects of the vaccine if
there are any for reference the New
England Journal of Medicine produced a
study in November of 2017 prec covid
entitled sudden Cardiac Arrest during
participation in competitive Sports in
which they state the incidence of sudden
Cardiac Arrest during participation in
sports was 76 cases per 100,000 athlete
years so in other words it just doesn't
happen that often and this growing list
of athletes dying is not
normal advancements in technology that
produced the new mRNA vaccine occurred
so rapidly that full understanding of
the effects of these vaccines short and
long term on human bodies is not known
and may not be fully known for many
years to come
we also know that information regarding
what's in the vaccines or any of the
test results uh pre-release won't be
available for up to 75 years now I don't
know about you but I probably won't be
here in 75 years to find out although I
might like to hang on just to see what's
actually
released therefore hb1 1634 is proposed
to establish a grant program for the
purpose of researching the effects if
any on the human body by vaccines
administered to prevent the virus
commonly known as covid-19 so some
questions that were are worth asking and
studying for an answer include do the
spike proteins produced by the vaccine
have the same effect on the body as the
spike proteins of the actual virus is
there any causal relationship between
mRNA vaccines and cardiac and other
injuries are there any noticeable and
notable differences in Damage Done to
the bodies of vaccinated and
unvaccinated people who die of the same
cause this bill would use money given to
the state for covid Relief thus would
not be be from the regular state budget
if the first phase of the study shows no
need for further study then no further
study is done and money set aside would
revert back to the general fund and
that's all perfectly acceptable science
is allowed this the scientific method
proper science is done you can have a
hypothesis you can think something is
going to be one way but hey you're
proven wrong there's nothing wrong with
being wrong the problem with being wrong
and going on and and saying something is
true when you know it's not true that's
where the problem breaks or are the
problems occur so this is scientific
inquiry that's all this is this is how
we learn we go in and with no
preconceived notions no pre-drawn
conclusions we allow the truth to Reve
reveal itself because a lot of policies
we are in this room all representatives
of policy makers we make decisions but
it's not just at the state level it's in
every level of our personal lives all
the way around the country every single
person makes decisions based on
information that they receive and if
they're given good information they can
make good decisions if they're given bad
information they can make bad decisions
so what we want to do is allow real
science to guide our decision making and
that's what hb1 1634 seeks to do that's
all I have sir thank you
representative does anyone have a
question representative kerk just a
quick one you alluded to it might take
75 years before we actually will know
the some of the science given that uh
why do you think it's reasonable that we
would find it with a state Grant within
one year well the release of information
uh from Mna and fiser about their the
studies that they is not because the
science isn't completed it's that's how
long they're taking to release the
information so it it's not that it's
taken 75 years to determine the science
it's taken 75 years to release the
records that no that's that's what
they're doing 500 pages a day or
something like that it's they said 7 5
years to release the information so it's
not the study hasn't been conducted it's
taken that long to release the
information so yes this information this
study could be done in one to two years
or uh over a period of two years with
with findings being
released like to call on our house
epidemiologist representative Solway oh
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative thank you for bringing
forth this bill I am always eagerly
interested in the granting process
having spent a career involved in it
from both sides as a grantee and a
grantor have you taken a look at the
mechanisms that foundations and NIH and
drug companies put into place to
generate Grant applications review them
fund them and monitor them have you
taken a look at those systems and asked
if the the state of New Hampshire is
capable of putting in place systems that
granting are you suggesting that there's
not a mechanism for the state to be able
to take
monies and issue a grant I'm not sure I
understand your question may follow up
um representative
um the drug companies NIH even our New
Hampshire charal Foundation have in
Place Extended panels of professionals
to review Grant
applications to they work hard to
generate those applications because they
they don't just you don't just put an ad
in the conquered Monitor and say all
those who want money please apply um and
then they have to monitor them it's an
extremely complex process that takes a
great deal of time to put in place and
to make work and I just wondered if you
had taken a look by the way I don't
disagree with almost all of what you
have
reviewed what I'm looking at is what
kind of structure do you need to put in
place in order to make research happen
and I've been on both sides of that and
I want to know if you've taken a look at
what those systems are and in fact
are we positioned to create those kinds
of systems here in New Hampshire that's
my question does the state presently
offer any kind of Grants at all for
scientific
inquiry the state does
contract research it does
smallscale contracts to serve the needs
of specific programs but general
research no I don't know of any states
that
out again this this sounds a lot more
complicated than it probably needs to be
there's clearly a mechanism for which to
conduct scientific study in the state of
New Hampshire we have state universities
we have uh they they can uh they can
apply for the grant there's somebody
wanting to get a PhD in something I'll
volunteer to do a PhD if somebody was
willing to award it to me just so I can
do the study for it I love science I'm a
meteorologist I'm an oceanographer so I
have allies after my name so I'd love to
do the research if someone's willing to
convey a PhD for me um but uh there
there has to be a mechanism I think it I
think it's a lot it doesn't matter what
representative representative
Shapiro yes thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking these questions I have
two questions
um first question is since I'm not
familiar with um the information you
cited about um athletes suddenly dying
could you provide myself or the
committee with uh some kind of reference
to that I can send you a link to a news
article that goes on to link to other
news articles uh because it it clear
lists okay I would appreciate that the
different an different stories yeah I
sure can follow up yeah my second
question is um you know you spoke very
eloquently about this being about
scientific inquiry yeah um that we don't
know the answers and that's all the more
reason why we have to um study this to
find the answers um and that was well
said I agree with you um however as we
all know this is an incredibly
contentious
area people um have very strong strong
opinions very strong ideas about this
um many of them I'm afraid fairly fixed
so I wonder if you've given thought
should this bill be passed and signed
and should this program um come to
fruition have you given thought about
how to make this
process um objective and um to deal with
the all the cont Consciousness that
would um likely come up in the process
in terms of who's appointed to decide on
grants in terms of how people apply for
Grants um I guess I'm wondering if
you've given thought about how to make
this a
um um scientific study in terms of
instead of it just becoming a political
brawl unfortunately representative thank
you for the question you're right uh
unfortunately this has become
contentious science has become
contentious um it it bothers me that
science has become corrupted in such a
way that um we're not even allowed to
ask questions anymore without being
labeled pejoratives of various sorts by
any by either side it's not the not a
political attack by on anyone uh but
science itself has taken a a real black
eye uh in in this area that's why when
it comes to it's a risk that science
must
take science is risky science is always
daring science is always bold there's
always somebody willing to say the Earth
is
round when everyone else says no it's
flat so it shouldn't be but it will be
uh that's why there's monies available
with caps on how much different group
this allows multiple uh recipients to
study you may get you may get all of
them come up with the same conclusion
they may all again there's the only way
is is to take and and take the the
Lessons
Learned whatever those lessons are and
just speak them and then
everybody you you can't hide it you
can't whitewash it you can't uh say
something and and you hide the truth you
need to let the truth the truth will
make us free that's the only thing I can
tell you it it's a risk that we're
willing to that we must be willing to
take to learn what the truth
is representative would you be prepared
to if you haven't done so already send
us in written form your opening
statement I sure can thank
you representative Leon was next um
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking the question
um I think that one of the important
points of this is that you're looking to
have a study of organs um as opposed to
live patients or anything else do you
think by um by having a process where
you're accessing these organs and
there's less risk than working with live
patients that that's going to be an
easier process and some of these other
ones that need the very rigorous Grant
programs thank you representative the
yes the the effect of on the organs um
is is really where the study goes um I I
picture two
hearts people have died of the same
cause roughly the same age person one
person is vaccinated one person is
unvaccinated in in my
mind given everything else being equal
the two hearts should show equal
damage but if there's a difference why
was there a
difference that's the answer that's the
question that needs to ask and that's
the answer that we're searching for we
know that the spike proteins I say we
know scientific study has indicated uh
that these Spike proteins cause blood
clots in the vessels around the heart
causing heart
failure so if we see in the in the
vaccinated heart or excuse me the
unvaccinated heart these Spike proteins
we could reasonably conclude this person
had covid at some time in their life if
we see the same Spike proteins of the
same quantities the same level of damage
then we could reasonably in the person
who who is vaccinated and we could
reasonably conclude that the vaccine had
no effect or we don't know for sure but
if we see that the vaccine the
vaccinated person had a
considerable greater quantity of the
spike proteins or blood clots or damage
uh over the unvaccinated person then we
might be able to conclude that the
vaccine but that's only one that's only
one person that's only one one one one
test there would have to be others it's
a science is is a repeatable thing you
can't go in do one test get one answer
and that's it you publish and that's it
you have to have multiple tests science
is a repeatable thing and it may be that
there was something just different who
knows but if four or five or six or 10
whatever different tests are conducted
and they all come up with the same
conclusion there's no effect or there is
an effect whatever the case may be but
yeah it would end up being the the the
testing would be would be done best on
those who have perished uh one way or
the other follow up follow up um would
you believe that Dr reneu verani or ver
the Dr who is a pathophysiologist who
determined what was causing late stent
thrombosis with drug eling stent was
able to do this with just one lab on a
far smaller budget than you're proposing
with these grants I not aware of that
I'm sorry I I know that there is a
doctor in Idaho who had conducted
autopsies
and had his results but again this is
um you know I didn't I didn't pull owed
his results to to because he's just one
person it's not an official scientific
study that he was conducting he's a he
was a physician or or some sort uh
actually he's a pathologist excuse me
he's a pathologist and so um but no I
again if they could we could do it on
less money fine and dandy I'm cool with
that less money more experiments thank
you there you go that's right
representative Canon Mr chair thank you
Mr chair thank you representative for
taking my question it's a simple
question why New Hampshire why should we
SP make this expenditure why aren't we
working with other organizations and
consortiums to fund a much larger study
than the $4 million you're asking for
over the next two years to do this um I
I find it hard to believe that people
aren't asking this question all across
the country and that large donors would
be available to fund such a study
but why should we the state of New
Hampshire and our taxpayers put this
money forward when it should be done on
a larger scale and hopefully industry
would fund such a
study well thank you for the question
representative Canon
uh the monies that are proposed being
used are monies that have the state has
received uh via covid relief so there
would be no additional burden placed on
us we are already the greatest
contributors as taxpayers so we are
basically taking money that we've
already paid uh and we're going to put
it to the use of this for the purpose of
the state of New hampsh to benefit the
state of New Hampshire why should the
state of New Hampshire do this why
should we wait for someone else to do it
let's be on The Cutting Edge Let's be
the ones to lead the pack maybe then
somebody else will say hey we'll do it
too maybe some industry will come along
and say Hey I want to do that too I I
don't know science science scientific
experiments lead to other scientific
breakthroughs and discoveries and so
that's the beauty of science so why not
start why not leave the pack why wait on
someone else to do
Merchant I think represent pushman had
first um thank you representative gon um
my question was
in regards to ensuring that there isn't
bias in the studies conducted in the
research
conducted um and I see that on page two
line 17 that the department adopts the
rules and I'm I'm assuming that that's
referring to the Department of Health
and Human Services since this is
141c um so the Department of Health and
Human
Services adopts rules relative to the
administration of the research grant
program including the application
procedure eligibility criteria Grant
dispersement and Reporting
requirements and um do you trust the
Department of Health and Human Services
to be unbiased in
that uh I would like
to I I I want
to um I I think I think about the
research that I have done and and
confronting um uh some of my professors
when I was at Naval Postgraduate School
earning my Master's Degree I mentioned
that um
money is real good at
corrupting and that you can get whatever
you pay
for and he didn't like that statement
calling it very cynical uh but he was
also one who was published saying that
the uh the polar ice cap would be
completely melted by September of
2013 and I asked him so what who cares
there's I've got a picture from a
submarine taken in 1951 or 1952 with the
caption where's the ice uh and so it's
happened before in the past why should
we care if it happens again in the
future and it's just a question not
trying to be a smart alec um but I think
money can uh can corrupt this as
unfortunately it's a risk we should be
willing to take uh that's why you have
multiple people conducting the study uh
it you have to have one Ru maker uh if
it's the the the entity in the State uh
is the Department of Health and Human
Services I would like to believe that
they would conduct this in and again
they're auditable they're accountable to
this body right here and as as it should
be uh and so if we believe that they are
misappropriating or they're mishandling
or they're misguiding or anything like
that we have the ability to put the
so I hope that answers your
question
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair and thank you for the
considerations representative
pishman Mr sorry representative a
question in regards to I'm not a
researcher um although spent some time
in a research lab but not really doing
the research so that's my claim to fame
and research but in saying that one of
the things I'm looking at is some can
help me or maybe you can help me as
well the organs that you're going to or
proposing someone do the research on how
are they going to be obtained and the
reason I asked the question we've gone
through a lot of histor this morning
about patient consent and therefore how
do we get patients consent to donate the
Oregon to this cause and if we do that
how are we going ensure that we have
some sort of a balanced approach to it
because I want to be sure that we have
patients on both sides of the aisle be
well vaccinated unvaccinated consenting
to it so as a non- researcher can you
help me explain how that would be done
in such a way is not
biased well thank you for your question
that is what
researchers uh that would
[Music]
be I mean how do they conduct scientific
research now on on anything they have to
be able to acquire the specimens uh
people donate their bodies to science
frequently I don't know how many that is
but it occurs it's it's how we develop
uh Cancer Treatments it's how we develop
new technologies for you name it and so
the availability should be there um
Others May because they know about this
may may want to specifically uh donate
for this particular cause um so that
would just be part of the the recipient
of the grant would have to be able to
acquire acquire by whatever means that
they presently would get their their
now representative Woods uh thank you Mr
chair there actually a question for you
will we uh will we be hearing from HHS
uh today regarding this matter I didn't
hear the last part but the first part
was will we be adjourning from HHS today
that will we be hearing from the
Department today regarding this matter
that's a yes
thank
you representative
kerk yes I I was curious are you aware
of any other basic research which is
funded at the state level and
administered by
DHHS I'm not aware of any other research
you representative
King thank you Mr chairman because I
think I would just got under the on that
one
louder thank you Mr chairman because I
think I just got under the wire on that
one you did and thank you rep uh
representative for uh taking my question
and it may just be um more of the same
questions the underlying current here it
um when I'm thinking of Grants I'm
thinking of money that's available and
I'm not sure where the grant money comes
from to be quite honest with you um but
um I'm just wondering why we need
legislation in order to do a study to um
to sort through all the fake news that
we get and that's on both sides by the
representative the desire
here
is everyone has a vested interest in in
knowing the answer whatever answer
answers come
the I don't see anyone presently at at
any of our state universities or at
Dartmouth or anywhere else saying hey
can we conduct a scientific study for
this purpose I've not seen any
volunteers sometimes you need to
stimulate to get the
volunteers U that's
okay uh to to to do that you're you are
incentivizing
study and uh and that's okay to do that
uh so that's why if there were another
way if if the department uh were to say
we're going to take some of our uh covid
relief funds and put if the governor
were to say gee I'd sure like to have a
a study conducted is there another way
of doing this I'm sure there probably is
is uh but at this point in time this is
the vehicle that I'm aware of uh to to
be able to accomplish this goal again we
we are we all have a a u a vested
interest in knowing what the reality of
this is and so we can put monies that
we've already uh spent through our tax
dollars that are now coming back to us
that we can allocate for the purposes
that we desire and this would be
something that we could put toward that
so the the funding is from uh from Co
relief funds you asked that question a
minute ago so representative did you
investigate to see if other states or
universities around the country are
launching similar studies I have not
found any other state official state
actions and I have not found any uh what
I'm able to find are uh the results of
studies
conducted U as they are published by the
National Institutes for health or
something else but I've not found
anything
specifically that uh proposed or that's
underway a lot of times they don't tell
you what's underway they wait until they
have the uh pre peer reviewed they may
release something and then it becomes
peer reviewed after that but uh but I've
not found anything specifically the
effects on the human body of if any uh
of uh covid vaccines so i' I've not
found anything like that in in any
University or state if there out there
I'm just not aware of it let's reverse
the flow how widely have you told other
legislators what you hope to do
here I didn't know I would be on WMU I
thought this was pretty going to be a
pretty boring Bill to be quite honest
with you nothing's boring in this
committee I love you guys this is great
uh I've got a great face for radio by
the way
um uh I actually did not share this with
but just a handful of Representatives
just to get a feel for if there would be
a desire for anything like this and the
feedback that I got was pretty positive
uh the the I I did have help uh from one
of our fellow representatives in
crafting the wording of the bill as he
has uh he's actually a a microbiologist
so it's that helped to uh to kind of get
my thinking about how to go about but he
he's done research grants and both
applying for and and writing research
grants so to get some of that techn
technical wording uh that needed to be
in there and so um but as far as
spreading it around asking for other
co-sponsors I thought this was kind of a
boring bill so I didn't even
ask representative Shapiro I believe you
had your hand
up you didn't oh you're waving off okay
anyone else for representative yes
representative
McKay um I am obviously very concerned
about this two minut
dollar and where it's coming from the uh
department is a huge department and has
concerns in many different parts of that
department my interest is in mental
health it's
extremely uh
underfunded and and you take out any one
part of it it upsets the whole
system so that I don't know if you've
talked to the department about this 2
million
uh at all and I take it we're going to
hear from the department but that
concerns me uh significantly to take
that much money away from the department
and what what will be lost in the
process is a major concern for me thank
you thank you representative in your
concerns I I share your concerns that's
why uh the the monies for this grant
would not be taken out of the
Department's regular budget uh it's
monies that are uh allocated to the
state of New Hampshire uh pursuant to
the American Rescue plan Act of
2021 uh and the and and will be
appropriated uh to to ensure that we can
actually uh use the funds for that
purpose if federal law tells us we can't
uh even do this uh which I not seen
anything in in the law I look to see if
this would be be out would not be
allowed and I've not found anything to
say that it couldn't be but if somebody
you know an attorney wanted to kill this
they could probably find some vague
wording uh to to uh get it uh get it
destroyed here uh but the the monies
would would come from that money not
anything that's that's that's already
budgeted in the state budget so there
would no be no adverse effect
uh on the department in that regard so
it literally comes down to the monies
that we are receiving from from oura
funds we're going to take a portion of
that for this purpose if federal law
says we can't do this then it's all
mooded and any money that's not spent
budget representative Leon thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative gson
um would you agree that this whole
vaccination vaccination process is
probably going to drag off drag on for
over a year and that this data if it
were to find no significant difference
would overcome a lot of objections that
people have to receiving it yes actually
representative that's that's a a great
observation that I I was hoping to make
before I finished here uh we hear the
term vaccine hesitant or vaccine
resistant or whatever like that this is
this is not coming from any anti-vax
position this is a pro- science position
period but I do believe that when we
learn the truth of what's happening if
there's any at all I think it would have
a very positive effect on people one way
or the other either there I think it was
pointed out a little bit ago uh about
the uh uh contention about this this uh
about this this subject and a part of
that is because we've not had the free
flow of of be of truthful information a
lot of information has been concealed
it's been spun one way or the other and
it's just not the right way to go about
making decisions the proper way so I
think this will settle a lot of fears
that people may still have one way or
the other so I'm not pushing a pro
vaccine or antivaccine it's not I'm not
pushing one way or the other I'm pushing
scientific discovery that's it
representative would you agree with me
that we are not just looking for an
objective answer to the question about
covid we may be defending science here
because one of the casualties in this
pandemic where I sit is the whole
question of what is science can we trust
science it's been hijacked or it's being
attempted to be hijacked by numbers of
parties across the Spectrum and an
objective study on this issue may have
the added benefit of rescuing science
would you agree I wholeheartedly agree
thank you for pointing that out uh again
I I I'm my scientific experience is in
meteorology and oceanography so I get to
deal with climate change right and if
you even ask a question you get called
to the principal's office I was teaching
at Plymouth state University and all I
did was prompt the students to ask
questions don't just take what you hear
on the news
as the gospel study it out ask questions
next thing you know I'm talking to the
chair of the department did you calling
to question climate change I said no I
got the students to start
thinking that's what science does yes
and science is being hijacked terribly
so let's bring it back thank you any
anyone
else thank you representative thank
you we've got the department to answer
some questions for us but first I'd like
to call on James Stewart we've had Mr
Stewart here earlier today and from a
non-scientist point of view but just a
guy I thought you spoke quite eloquently
and you've asked to speak for two to
three minutes and go for it thank you
now that I've heard a lot that I didn't
know exactly what was going to come up
i' surely like about 15 but uh you could
come back next week you well if you can
extend it to Five I'll be happy but you
nail you thank you sir you nailed it
right there science needs to be defended
be defended is not a shame science is
science science is truth science is
facts science is the investigation of
the
world and you discover what's there and
what's there is what's there you don't
turn it into politics or twisted
around part of the problem here is that
we don't understand enough
about we don't understand the fact that
this genetic therapy inoculation that is
happening in the world and that is being
actually pushed by the DHHS of New
Hampshire and when they come up here
they're going to be representing their
dollars they want their dollars and
they've got their agenda and that's all
they're going to want they don't want it
they want s they want science out there
they don't want facts and facts careful
careful I'm saying what I believe is the
truth I understand that and here's
another truth point of order Mr chair
yes point of order is it not our
practice and procedure that you may not
State what you may not
cast we don't presume to know what we
cannot presume someone else's motivation
that's correct you can you can State
your own thoughts but not presume
someone else's motivation okay I'll mend
that too that my thoughts are that
that's probably going to Happ time will
tell um so one thing we need to
understand is that this is not a vaccine
everybody keeps calling it vaccine it's
not a
vaccine and the CDC totally agreed with
that up until about 30 days ago when
without your knowledge without making
much a awareness of it to the media or
anyone else very quietly the CDC changed
the definition of vaccine did you know
that no probably most of you didn't
that's my opinion by the way probably
most of you didn't we're going to be
discussing that at some point continue
please so what they did is it used timeh
honored definition of vaccine was that
which immunizes you but now it's so
obvious that the vaccine is not safe and
not effective
it doesn't immunize you you need a
booster how many here have to have a
booster of small poox
diptheria tetus once every 10 years you
know 10 years it's not like every three
months it's not like multiple boosters
like they're going to keep making money
on and the answer there is follow the
money Trail as far as the 75 years for
the FDA to bring this out it's the FDA
by the way um that is says this going to
take 75 years why here's the here's the
short answer mostly money they don't
want to bring this out they're
obfuscating it's totally apparent to
everybody involved that that's what
they're doing they could bring this out
in 75 hours if they wanted to certainly
75 days 75 years is just saying oh we we
really don't want to bring it out
because we don't want the truth
known as far as something else you need
to understand that's diabolical about
this the spike protein that we need to
discover more about and this is the
reason we need to Discover it this
wasn't totally made clear um this what
this genetic therapy solution is it it
it involves an
encapsulated alterate
alterating Gene alterating um entity
it's encapsulated in a what's a uh a
lipid nanop particle it's a very small
particle that's allowed to get into your
cells because it uses a a fat coating
because it gets into your cells more
easily that way because your cells are
covered with fat when it when it accepts
this it causes your cell this is what
needs to be
understood this genetic therapy causes
your cell and every one of you who's
been vaccinated is consented to be part
of this worldwide trial this big
experiment because it causes your cell
to make the spike protein no it's not
just a spike protein that comes from the
covid-19 infection itself you are making
Spike protein with your cells it's been
caused to happen by this therapy two
minutes
okay when that happens it floods your
system with these Spike protein thereby
poisoning you the thought was that you
would react to this Spike protein and
make antibodies it might happen somewhat
but they didn't count on that this Spike
protein goes all over the place in your
body it's and the lipid neop particle
gets to
deposited also the Japanese have shown
that it goes into mostly women's ovaries
and into the marrow of your blood of
your bones but it gets deposited in lots
of places and when it when this mRNA
altering Factor goes into cells it was
supposed to stay in your muscle cells in
your arm it didn't sometimes it travels
in your your Venus system throughout
your entire bodies especially when it
against in the very small cap litters
when it makes the spike protein it goes
in the very your body makes it these
Spike proteins locate in your very small
capillaries and plug them up that's what
causes some of the the the blood plots
I'm hurrying here because I've only got
so much time and the spike protein
sometime is grown in various cells that
cause your body to attack it because it
knows it's a foreign particle when this
happens it causes some of the partis and
and myotis and things like that that's
why these these these uh Athletes World
known athletes are just I've literally
seen many pictures of them just falling
over dead we're going to find out more
and more about this and it's a shame
that we have to need our own scientific
study in the state of New Hampshire 30
seconds to to prove that there's
something
nefarious that's a light word going on
here because there's lots of study out
there The Hope here is folks that if we
have our own maybe we'll hear about it
maybe you folks will hear about it maybe
more people will be hearing about the
negative effects of this so-called
vaccine and at some point the Tipping
Point will come where all of us will
know more and more and more and thank
you so much thank you appreciate you
coming
back we now call on John Williams and
Abby Rogers from the Department of
Services
and good afternoon uh chairman Pearson
and members of the committee and I know
this is the last bill of a day we're
really primarily here to respond to
questions uh I do want to uh introduce
obviously Abby Rogers she's our she is
our legislative lison for our division
of Public Health and she actually
assisted me and our financial managers
in conducting the financial review So to
that extent we do have personal
knowledge over the fiscal note that was
produced by the legis assed budget
Assistance Office uh two people who are
two of your members uh um who really
stated something I think that was very
helpful to this conversation were both
representative Solway and also
representative kushman represent Solway
started off the conversation saying it
is unique in you in in this proposed
Bill to approach a research project in
the way that it's being presented here
uh by um the representative who's
sponsoring it and um and that is true to
my knowledge we don't have specific
types of procurements that we do for
particular research and that actually um
goes to represent kushman I I would use
a slightly different word than trust uh
and bias but I would absolutely agree
with represent kushman in her
observations that because this is not
typically a role department does to my
knowledge even another state agency
similar to us doing this kind of pement
for research that it does raise question
should best be managed and I think that
that's goes back to what re of Sol way
started off in this conversation and and
his questions that there is an
established process you know whether
through the National Institute of Health
or others how you get to good science so
although we can applaud the bill sponsor
for coming up with a unique reproach for
trying to fund such research it is
something very vastly different and in
particularly could run into the issues
that I think that representative kushman
was identifying in her commentary and
point in case is when we do a
procurement as an agency we do quite a
few procurements as an agency to devel
to deliver services to the citizens of
New Hampshire we have hundreds and
hundreds of procurements that are out
there and as we go through that process
we're required by law to issue what they
call a request for proposals those
requests for proposals are designed
specifically more for a service
generating uh entity not to procure
researchers to do research the other
concerns the other concerns it's not
saying that it's limited that you
couldn't use it for those vehicles but
it is a unique approach to using our
current RFP process also with requests
for proposals as you're probably aware
they go through the process of a review
by governor and Council so it is
bringing more into not only an executive
branch agency to be in charge of putting
together this research but also bringing
in that process that has to play out
with um with other types of contracts
that have nothing to do with research so
I do think it's an important point to
raise in terms of who may be best uh
suited to doing these kind of research
and and it's tried and true the academic
world the world that does research is
really in a good position to doing this
kind of work now one of the things that
certainly we can follow up in addition
to the request that was made of repr uh
Reon to look at what other states are
doing we could certainly look to see
what is out there in terms of current
research on the subject matter to at
least try to see if there's anything
that we could offer uh to to this
committee so uh going Beyond just the
issue of the procurement process and
this just not being a well-fitted suit
to doing research there is the issue of
and it's one of my and I have to be just
very direct one of my pet peeves lately
over when we do fiscal analysis on bills
that it's somehow couched in terms of an
appropriation when I think of an
appropriation I think of general fund
Appropriations that you the legislature
provide to a state agency to be able to
execute the work that's being requested
and although I do appreciate the novel
use of the uh arpa funds which uh are
being discussed here those American
Rescue plan act funds are actually
administered through the governor's
office of relief and recovery and they
have a spef a very specific process
outside of the scope of this legislation
for entities to make requests for those
funds and those funds are totally
Federal so you can't lapse those funds
into the state general funds because
there are never State funds to begin
with so there's some anomalies with the
bills that you would if you are going to
pursue this as an Avenue for research
there are necessary amendments that are
going to have to take place to align
this with the actual practicality of um
How These funds should be administered
so there is no guarantee with these arpa
funds and in fact the arpa funds are
identified and I know uh Miss Rogers has
with her kind of a list of the things
that we know typically the funds are
used for for public health purposes for
providing uh you know First Responders
Frontline people who deal with this
issue with um with money to be able to
address ID 19 so there is questions
whether or not this would in fact pass
Federal mustard to begin with and
there's nothing in the legislation that
absolves the department even with due
diligence to seeking These funds to not
have to do what is required under this
uh proposal in the event that the arpa
funds are not made available to the
department and so with that I think
that's kind of the totality of at least
the high level overview and some other
limitations within the grant I'll just
mention one other you'll see that
there's a specific a cap of
$225,000 per uh vendor uh per presumably
researcher to doing their funds so that
chopped up between and it's not just $2
million it's actually $4 million over
the course of two State fisal years and
so that $4 million carved up in uh by
chunks of
$250,000 shows you that we're going to
have a number of vendors that are going
to be out there and perhaps some with
competing interest in terms of what they
may represent in terms of the research
it also is different because it asked
this committee to actually and also the
Senate policy committee on health to act
as an arbitrator on the research to
determine whether or not you go to the
next phase of the research in in the
project again a very Noble different
approach and I would just suggest by the
wisdom of folks like rbson kushman who
identify that there are some inherent
misalignments with an executive branch
agency managing this I wouldn't I
wouldn't use necessarily the word trust
but it's just you you ask the right
people to do the right things and we do
great work but this type of work this is
very novel not only for us but any other
state agency and I think what was
suggested by represent solay is really
what should be looked at from this
committee as an appropriate way to
looking at this research issue so with
that I would ask Miss Rogers if she has
additional commentary because I know she
knows the details because she actually
did um the uh Yan's work around the
fiscal analysis on the bill working with
her staff and and myself included
sure thank you John um I did want to
just mention that we did complete the
fiscal note on the bill as requested by
the LBA um it tasks the department with
a variety of things from um Drafting and
proposing administrative rules um
establishing an application process
toward grant funding um entering into
contracts with recipients monitoring
contract performance measures and vendor
activities and paying invoices it also
would require some additional staff that
um is not appropriated for unless we
were to receive arpa funds um and that
is uncertain as John had alluded
to the bill is now in possession of the
committee I think we have before us an
extraordinary opportunity too often the
Hampshire is
last on things sometimes we're first
wouldn't this be a good opportunity for
us to be first in this I'm going to
ask individuals in this committee to
email me if you are interested in
serving on a work group this is an early
bill it's got to be out the door in the
first half of February if you're
interested in serving on a work group to
make this an extraordinary
bill please email me and I will appoint
a work
group you will work with representative
gon who is the Prime
sponsor and attorney Williams who is
bringing all kinds of things that this
group will need to
know any
questions ranking
member I actually have a question of the
folks in the seat rather than the
procedure that you just outlined is that
okay hold hold my thought go
ahead my question and I thank you for
answering my other question which was is
the legislature even involved in the
allocation of arpa funds which I didn't
think they
were um
so
uh with respect to the well let me ask
let me separate it into two questions
could not the bill sponsor simply ask
the the governor's office to talk to his
commission about the allocation of the
arpa funds and do it that way that's
number
one yes I believe so and my second
second question is should we follow the
procedure outlined here could you aside
from the issue of the allocations in
various years and I assume it was going
to finance so that would be worked out
um could you remind us how long the ru
making process T typically takes if this
bill doesn't uh take effect till June
30th could you give us a timeline on the
ru process following that I could
briefly um although I do not I'm not
involved directly with administrative
rules I've been doing this work and
enough working with people who do it to
have an idea of what the timelines are
so even with the most ambitious of
schedules it typically would take around
six months from initiating the rule
process to prating final rules uh you
know so that is even in with it being an
ambitious process so there are some
timing issues relative to standing this
program up because it is contemplated if
there is a need for administrative rules
and I have to say that's a big question
mark because ABS in the legislation is
what we would actually have to do to
promulgate rules and I'd have to get
with the policy folks to find out what
type of rules would be needed sometimes
in legislation it's self-executing
because legislation either gives us the
authority to do things without rules or
clearly identifies what's our rules and
responsibility but in the absence of
that kind of Direction a fair statement
would be at least 6 months from
initiating Ro process to finalizing the
roles anyone else with questions for the
Solway representative Solway into the
mic closer please for the old people
here would you believe thank you would
you believe that the National Institute
of heart lung and blood diseases a
member organization of the national
Institutes of Health has as we speak a
request for proposals an RFP in exactly
this area with proposals due February
5th ample money to fund those projects
decisions after submission February 5th
would probably come within nine months
with a start date to be about a year
from now would you believe that with all
du respect of committee I actually feel
like I'm watching my cousin Vinnie right
now and I'd like to say I'd absolutely
believe in that so what's wrong with my
cousin Vinnie I love the movie oh so do
I anyone
else representative kerk um just because
I you you mentioned a lot about the fact
that the department usually works on
Contracting for services and so on with
rfps do you feel that DHHS actually has
the expertise to make appropriate
decisions about um funding re basic
research and uh I mean do we have people
in the department capable of doing that
or would that need to be contracted out
as
well um I would think that we would have
to partner with an academic academic
institution um or or turn that over to
them uh to to go through that process um
follow up followup and is that accounted
for in the fiscal Noe as well because I
assume they aren't going to do it for
free
uh no I would think that would be
additional but I can go back and look
through that the fiscal note thank you
thank
[Music]
you I see no more questions thank you so
much and just to repeat if you would
like to be on this work Group which we
means a group that works and report back
with an amendment probably the first
week of February please let me know you
can let me know afterwards or you can
email me with that I close the hearing
on Bill 1634 FNA and we are finished for
today we will see you all next Tuesday
at
Day
e
for